Guten Morgen, Linus.
Guten.
Sag mal, wusstest du, es gab eine Excel-Meisterschaft.
Oh äh wann war die denn.
Am vier Millionen vierhundertsiebzigtausendfünfhundert Prozent.
Logbuchnetzpolitik Nummer vierhundertsechsunddreißig vom zweiundzwanzigsten August zwanzig zweiundzwanzig. Wir sind wieder da. Hat keine sechs Wochen gedauert.
Das ist blöd, solche langen Pausen zu haben. Aber jetzt interessiert mich doch äh welche Ransomwaage hat denn jetzt die Excel-Meisterschaften gewonnen.
Ja, das war ja so einzelne äh Kombartanten, wenn du da irgendwie das äh Video anschaust, wird dich lustig. Also das sind so Nerds.
Alle so nach so Buchhalterner Nerds aus.
Ach was.
Fast alle. Und es ist wirklich es ist wirklich also ich glaube wenn man da drin steckt in dem Thema, ist es ist es wirklich unterhaltsam. Es ist so eine Art,
Screensharing Veranstaltung, wo dann die Teilnehmer,
So äh im Ausscheidemodus irgendwie alle dieselbe Aufgabe lösen. Jeder äh parallel und du siehst sozusagen, was hier auf dem Screen mit ihrem Excel so veranstalten und dann halt den totalen,
Formel und äh,
Seitenwahnsinn da, machen mit Zwischenrechnung und Pipapo und kriegen irgendwie so Aufgaben, ähm,
was weiß ich, so simulierte Regatta oder Plattform Games oder Slot Machines, wo sie dann irgendwie
Ergebnisse ausrechnen müssen und das ist alles so total komplex und hängt voneinander ab und pipapo und dann haben sie sowieso eine halbe Stunde Zeit da ihren Formelkram reinzumachen und dieses vorbereitete Excelsheet
automatisch irgendwie aus, was irgendwie richtig ist und äh wer zuerst fertig ist äh kommt weiter oder hat dann am Schluss gewonnen.
Ich war mal äh oh wie hieß es denn? Irgendwie so eine Landwirtschaftsmesse. Auf in in ähm in Hannover, jeweils mit Treckern und so, ne.
Da war die deutsche Meisterschaft oder was im im Landwirtschaftssimulator. Das ist ein bisschen so.
Trecker fahren.
So Kobaden spielen mit äh mit Heuballen und solchen Sachen, ja?
Und äh irgendwie schnell das Feld bestellen und so und diese dieses E-Gaming ist ja eh äh äußerst äh unterhaltsam, ne, wenn die dann da in diesen Sportsitzen, sitzen mit irgendwelchen Teflonbeschichteten, Mauspads und so um um irgendwie mit dem Trecker schnell zu fahren.
Ja war gut.
Die haben dann auch so richtig Fans.
Ja sicher.
Oder siehst du mal, so sogar als staubtrockener Buchhalter bist du noch in der Lage, dir irgendwie so eine Fan-Community aufzubauen heutzutage, indem du halt einfach Excel-Weltmeister wirst.
Jetzt verstehe ich, warum du die ganze Zeit von Buchhaltung.
Man muss auch äh für die Zeit.
Als I-Buchhalter. E-Sports-Buchhalter.
Vielleicht läuft's ja irgendwann mit dem Podcasting nicht mehr so sehr.
Ja.
Da muss man dann schon noch eine zweite Möglichkeit haben.
Du kannst dir deine Steuererklärung auf Twitch äh Stre.
Das Buch war hier auf dreizehn zwölf.
Da lege ich jetzt noch mal ein paar richtig schöne Verrechnungskonten an. Geht alles auf null.
Ja, wunderbar und wer hat gewonnen? Der wenn man Exe Frage hat an den Wänden, der kriegt die halben Stunde. Das ist doch gut.
Können das auch ganz gut.
Hallo Andrew, ich habe eine Frage. Dauert auch nur eine halbe Stunde.
Ja also äh die kennen sich auf jeden Fall aus. War schon erstaunlich, ein ein Leben in der Tabellenkalkulation.
Wir haben äh in der letzten Sendung haben wir die Zentralstelle zu Pflege Antifaschistischen Brauchtums äh gegründet.
Ohne gesetzliche Grundlage erstmal, die reichen wir nach und äh die hat jetzt auch ein Logo, ja? Twitter User Skat hat uns direkt das Logo dazu gemacht, also wir haben da jetzt auch schon einen Briefkopf und ähm können wir jetzt eigentlich,
zu Tat schreiten.
Loslegen, brauchen nur noch einen Geschäftsführer dafür.
Ja, das ist doch schön,
Äh was gibt's noch? Ach ja, wir sind also wir sind hier quasi gerade beim Feedback-Blog und da habe ich mir gedacht, ich habe auch Feedback bekommen,
und zwar auch wirklich gar nicht so schlechtes Feedback. Ähm als wir uns mit Impfpässen und so auseinandergesetzt haben, ähm letztes Jahr, welches da wir irgendwann letztes Jahr, ne? Vorletztes Jahr, wann kamen die Impfpässe? Das ist ja alles so
12und November, einundzwanzig ähm.
Ähm habe ich äh formuliert, ne, haben wir uns ein bisschen mit der Sicherheit von Impfpässen auseinandergesetzt und da hatte ich auch so einen Blogpost geschrieben.
Indem ich mich gegen Impfzwang auswende, ja, wo ich sage, wenn wir mehr äh wenn wir mehr Privilegien an Impfpässe binden, steigt die Motivation zur Fälschung stärker als die Motivation zur Impfung. Geringe, positive Anreize können Menschen umstimmen,
einfacher Zugang tut sein übriges. Reakstanz ist ein nicht zu unterschätzendes psychologisches Phänomen. Also ich habe mich da gegen,
Impfpflicht ausgesetzt äh ausgesprochen.
Ging ging Impfpflicht ausgesprochen und dann äh habe ich den habe ich aber den den Blogpost beendet mit lasst euch impfen ihr Deppen,
Und jetzt gibt es irgendwie so ein so einen Onlinepranger von von irgendwelchen Querdenkern, ja, die äh,
irgendwie ähm Leute sammeln und Zitate sammeln von Menschen die,
ja was weiß ich mit ausgegrenzt haben ja, die zur Impfpflicht oder so sich geäußert haben und äh gibt's so ein so ein ja so ein,
mitleidenden Fit zu bemitleidenden Veteraner, der offenbar diese Seite auch aufgesetzt hat oder sich auf jeden Fall sehr damit beschäftigt
Und der äh hat einen Fred gemacht, indem er quasi so die schlimmsten auflistet, ja. An erster Stelle.
Udo Lindenberg. Ja und Udo Lindenberg hat gesagt, wenn die Hirntoten Risikopiloten durch die Aerosole zischen, wird es ganz viele noch erwischen. Ja, dafür ist er an Platz eins.
Fisch schon mal ist ja lustig, ne?
Freuen, also endlich mal wieder Platz eins.
Mal wieder Platz eins Udo Lindenberg. Ich bin an Platz zwei hinter Udo Lindberg, so.
Wow und wer ist hinter dir? Irgendwelche anderen Prominenten?
Nicht irgendwelche ist mir egal was guckt nach oben, nicht nach unten.
Ja aber die Meisterschaft hast du knapp äh verpasst, ne?
Zweiter Platz hinter Udo ist okay. Ja, hinter Udo man hat eigentlich immer den zweiten Platz hinter Udo.
Egal so das das ist das Beste, was du kriegen kannst. Ja finde ich auf jeden Fall ganz lustig. Ah ja, okay. Dann haben wir ähm,
die lange Zeit nicht mehr über unsere oder ich habe lange Zeit nicht mehr über unsere Ukraine äh Spendenaktion gesprochen.
Aufgerufen.
Genau. Insgesamt sind da 6252 Euro und 5 Cent eingegangen. Finde ich schon eine relativ große Summe Geld.
Was ist das in Prozent.
Ich kann das äh warte, kann ich ausrechnen,
Moment, gebe ich einfach hier ein.
Nach 30 Minuten, ne?
Das kriege ich hin.
Dachten auch so manche bei der Meisterschaft, aber war dann doch ganz schön schwierig.
Nee, äh na ja, das ist relativ einfach. Das sind sechshundertfünfundzwanzigtausendzweihundertfünf Prozent.
Einfach nur nochmal multipliziert. Äh bei beim Datum ist es weniger intuitiv, was da rauskommt.
Da ist die Frage, wie du die Zahl eingibst und so.
Ja, da fällt mir noch was ein, ja. Also okay, genau, sechstausendzweihundertzweiundfünfzig Euro. So, dann haben wir die ja für die Wohnungen äh äh,
also ausgegeben für die Wohnungsmiete, ja, erstmal für die ähm,
Familie, von der die Rede war, die bei Tobi wohnt und äh dann haben wir ja noch eine weitere Familie äh äh gefunden.
Die äh dringende Unterstützung brauchte. So, jetzt passiert aber Folgendes.
Das Geld wurde dann immer wieder erstattet vom Amt, so,
ein bisschen ungünstig war, weil das Geld sollte ja weg. Und ich hatte ja anfangs Sachen das Geld ähm,
also Geld, was zu viel ist und damit quasi fast alles zu viel äh geht dann eben äh wird gespendet in andere Projekte der äh,
Flüchtlingsunterstützung oder der Geflüchtetenhilfe?
Ähm also da ging also einmal 2000 an eine Familie, wo keine Erstattung kommt. Das hatte ich beim letzten Mal schon erzählt.
Dann haben wir 1.800 Euro an den Verstehbahnhof äh gespendet,
für Kunstworkshops mit Kindern und Jugendlichen. Da haben wir auch ein paar Links in den Shownotes. Die haben da ähm im verstehbaren Hof, ich weiß nicht, irgendwie über zehn Menschen waren das, glaube ich, insgesamt. Ähm
die,
so in ihrer äh Umgebung da wohnen oder auch im verstehbahnhof wohnen und die mit Kindern und Jugendlichen der äh Kunstworkshops machen.
Die sind von dieser Kunsthochschule in natürlich nicht die Stadt.
Warte mal, ich muss hier, ich habe zu viele Links, ja, die da ist also eine Kunsthochschule in der Ukraine, von der sind diese Menschen äh,
und da jetzt auf dem Instagram-Account ist das in der Sprache, die lesen kann. Also,
könnt ihr nachlesen in den Shownotes Club von der Kunsthochschule haben halt für Kinder und Jugendliche mit und dann natürlich quasi äh die von Menschen, die schon da wohnen, aber eben auch Kindern, die in der Region dann eben untergekommen sind ähm sehr schöne
die wir da äh unterstützen konnten. Der Verstehbahnhof ist ja in Fürstenberg an der Havel,
und ähm Daniel Domscheid Berg und,
waren ja auch schon mal bei uns in der Sendung zu Gast. Das war glaube ich in der zweihundert, wenn ich mich nicht täusche,
War das die zweihundertsechsundfünfzig? Ja, zweihundertsechsundfünfzig. Ähm genau, da kann man sich über also haben wir glaube ich auch über dieses Projekt gesprochen und das ist, glaube ich, sehr sehr schön ne in Kunst und Kultur, damit die,
Kinder da was Schönes erfahren und auch die Künstlerinnen ähm ja Möglichkeiten haben hier in Deutschland zu wirken,
Dann sind äh zwei.
2hundert war's im Übrigen. LNP 2hundert war.
LMP zweihundert, okay. Dann haben wir 200 Euro gespendet für eine Reise zum Konsulat, um dort Papierkram zu erledigen. Es war nämlich günstiger, nach München zu fahren,
um das Papier in dem Papierkram zu erledigen als den in Berlin zu erledigen, wo die Wartezeiten einfach irre waren, sodass wir da einer Familie helfen konnten, den Papierkram schneller hinter sich zu bringen.
Und dann blieben quasi
äh oh je also da blieb eine Summe über, von der die Hälfte 1126,25 ist und äh diesen äh Betrag, also die eine Hälfte haben wir an den Support gespendet,
und äh die andere Hälfte an leaven no one behind.
So das so ist quasi dieses Geld jetzt am in Endstationen gelangt. Zusätzlich haben wir mit dem Geld eine Familie von März bis August untergebracht.
Und äh die Familie also bis Ende August jetzt bald. Die Familie hat jetzt eine Anschlussunterkunft gefunden äh die dann äh eben auch entsprechend äh finanziert wird direkt,
und ähm ich denke, da haben wir mit diesen Spenden doch einen relativ großen äh,
Ja, relativ viel machen können mit dem Geld und da glaube ich, ist sehr gut äh untergekommen.
An dieser Stelle nochmal vielen Dank für alle an alle die da mitgemacht haben ich hoffe diese vielfältigen Unterstützung für eben in an dieser Stelle zwei Familien und die ganzen Projekte die ich gerade genannt habe,
ist in eurem Interesse gewesen und wir waren beide, also Tobi und ich durchaus überwältigt von der Menge Geld, das war dann so tatsächlich fast so ein bisschen blöd, weil auf einmal also auch wirklich die Frage war, wo bringt man das jetzt am besten,
Als es dann zurückkam vom Amt, ja, wo bringt man das Geld am besten unter? Aber bei äh leave no one behind,
also beim leave now waren wir halt Ukraineprojekt und beim Berlin Support ist es glaube ich sinnvoll ähm untergebracht. Interessanterweise ist an beiden allerdings die die gleiche.
Ähm die gleiche äh Organisation, die Spenden begünstigte,
nämlich äh der Civil Fleet ja Support oder wie heißt diese dieser Verein? Support Verein, ja, die machen, das ist also eine ähm.
NGO gemeinnützig, die unter anderem auch in der ähm in der Seenotrettung ähm,
Finanzierungen und Spenden annimmt, ja also in diesem Bereich äh die Organisation unterstützt und die auch äh quasi die Kabul-Luftbrücke unterstützt hat.
Cabu-Luftbrücke war jetzt einjähriges äh Jubiläum. Wir erinnern uns ähm nach 20 Jahren,
ja wie soll man das sagen? Was was ist da jetzt der richtige Begriff.
Konflikt.
Konfliktbesatzung ich weiß es nicht was da was der politisch korrekte oder inhaltlich korrekte Zustand Afghanistan.
Zieht sich glaube ich auch äh einer klaren Definition.
Jedenfalls haben sich ja sehr überstürzt und sehr wenig vorbereitet dort die US-amerikanischen und äh deutschen Kräfte zurückgezogen,
und haben jene, die über 20 Jahre mit ihnen dort eng zusammengearbeitet haben im Sinne der afghanischen Demokratie zurückgelassen.
Taliban haben innerhalb kürzester Zeit das Land wieder übernommen und die haben natürlich nur so Mittel.
Gute Pläne für den Umgang mit diesen Menschen, weshalb es sehr wichtig war die da schnell aus dem Land zu holen und denen auch, sage ich mal, die,
Anerkennung zu geben für das, was sie da geleistet haben in diesem Land,
was sie auch riskiert haben, ne, für das sie jetzt eben sie jetzt eben unter den Taliban in großer Gefahr schweben. Ähm
Bundesregierung war nicht sinnvoll darauf vorbereitet, die alte Bundesregierung war nicht sinnvoll darauf vorbereitet und hat da auch nicht unbedingt vorgesehen diese Menschen zu evakuieren. Es gab diese ganz dramatischen Bilder, wo Menschen versucht sind versucht haben, über die,
über das Fahrwerk an an Flugzeugen mitzufliegen und runtergefallen sind und in dieser Zeit hat eben,
hat sich die Initiative Kabul Luftbrücke sehr, sehr schnell äh zusammengetan, um eben auch ein Flugzeug zu schattern und äh Menschen zu evakuieren,
Aber nicht nur das mit dem Flugzeug gemacht, sondern ähm dann auch weitere über die die weiteren Monate mit äh Autos quasi äh,
Flucht aus Afghanistan organisiert und zwar oh Mann, jetzt kommt wieder meine.
Geographie, meine Geografie-Kenntnisse. Ich will jetzt nix Falsches sagen, weil ich gucke lieber nochmal nach. Ich habe das das Land, über das sie gefahren sind im Kopf, aber da ich so schlecht bin in ähm.
In Geographie schaue ich nochmal ganz schnell. Ja über.
Über Pakistan, genau, also hatte ich richtig im Kopf, dann sind sie rübergefahren und äh genau, das äh alles weiß ich aus einer Fernsehdokumentation äh mit dem Namen Mission Kabul Luftbrücke in der ARD Mediathek zu sehen,
die kann ich auf jeden Fall empfehlen. Genau das einjährige Jubiläum war vor einigen Tagen war ich auch hier in Berlin zu den,
Festigkeiten, wo,
viele der Menschen aus dieser Mission Kabul Luftbrücke Dokumentation dann auch waren, die Menschen, die da auch die,
Hilfe geleistet haben, den äh Flüchtenden und so, das war sehr äh ja, beeindruckend. Und genau diese Sendung in der Mediathek kann ich sehr empfehlen. Es gibt auch noch einen Podcast,
der leider nur auf Spotify zu hören ist und unsere Hörerinnen und Hörer hören ja nur richtige Podcasts und nicht äh PayWal und Werbe zugeballerte Spotify-Sachen. Äh weshalb wir den leider,
Gar nicht hören oder empfehlen, ja? Aber die äh die ARD Mediathek Doku ist schon äh sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr beeindruckend, kann ich sehr empfehlen.
Dann warst du ja äh bei einer Konferenz The next Web, das nächste Web, wie viel haben wir jetzt eigentlich schon durch?
Ja ähm die heißen schon länger so, also The Next Webhed, die hießen schon so, da war's glaube ich noch da waren wir noch alle im Web eins oder so von einer von einer gefühlten Web eins.
Heißt, äh der,
Verlag im weitesten Sinne diese Konferenz macht. Ich hatte glaube ich auf äh vor ein oder zwei Sendungen mal davon erzählt, dass ich da einen Podcast äh einen Podcast einen Vortrag
einen Vortrag gehalten habe mit dem Titel ähm da war da war also quasi eine,
Stage, die sich den ganzen Tag, wo du die nur von irgendwelchen Blockchain-Start-ups ähm bespielt
und als abschließender Vortrag durfte ich dann mal ihre Geschäftsmodelle und ihre Interessen näher beleuchten,
Ähm ich hatte glaube ich nur 20 Minuten, weshalb das unglaublich komprimiert war und ähm war sehr überrascht, weil also der Vortrag ist sehr, sehr gut angekommen. Ich meine, ich habe so,
hat ja ein Gefühl dafür in der Regel kommen meine Vorträge ganz okay an. Aber das ist halt so richtig langen Applaus über, hört mal auf zu klatschen gebt und das nachher bin so besoffen nach Hause gekommen, weil weil alle möglichen Leute mir noch ein Bier ausgeben wollten
da kostenlos war, ja. Komm, wir geben dir noch ein Freibier aus.
Dann nachher weitergezogen. Das war in in Amsterdam ähm und ja war alles sehr schön.
Die wirken tatsächlich, man sieht das so im Video so ein bisschen, wenn die wenn die Fragen kommen, so. Also ich hatte auch so ein bisschen den Eindruck, dass alle so ein bisschen befreit wirken, weil sie äh schon wohl so das Gefühl hatten, die ganze Zeit nur mit Bullshit,
zu geballert zu werden und so war's ja wahrscheinlich auch. Du äh beziehst dich auch auf dein Vorredner.
Der war geil.
Das musste noch mal vielleicht den auch nochmal raussuchen, weil ich nicht wusste, was jetzt vor dir dran war.
Also der Vorredner hat irgendwie so,
also seine, sein Pitch war, der hatte schön so ein Start-up die jetzt irgendwie so eine Welt machen, ja, also die machen eine Welt, also so was so was wie second life oder so was, ja und in dieser Welt verkaufen sie Grundstücke auf der Blockchain,
Und wir alle wissen ja, die Grundstückspreise steigen, ja und deswegen müssen wir früh die Grundstücke kaufen. Und denkst dir so, weißt du,
not so sure, weil irgendwie ich mein Grundstückspreise sind halt schon ein bisschen daran gebunden, wo sie sind und dass es da irgendwie limitiert ist so, ne und diese künstliche Begrenzung wollen die natürlich auch schaffen und na ja, der wollte dann da dann hat ihn irgendwann in den Fragen, hat ihn jemand gefragt
ja okay, aber was soll ich denn mit meinem Grundstück, wie soll du sagst die ganze Zeit das Grundstück verdient Geld für mich? Ähm,
Womit denn, ne? Und dann hat er irgendwie so seine Idee war, dass man Überflugsrechte, also wenn jemand über dein Grundstück fliegt, um sich das anzuschauen.
Muss er dafür bezahlen. Also so eine total so eine richtige,
irgendwie so und ich wirklich das war wirklich ein einfaches äh also es ich habe da noch irgendwie gesessen Vortrag da angeschlossen und übertragen Pipapo,
und als ich das gehört habe, habe ich gedacht, so oh Mann ey Junge tut mir leid, aber da werde ich jetzt so viele so viele Witze drüber machen können, das das war schon wirklich bemitleidenswert. Ja genau, aber genau der Link ist äh ist auf.
Ist auch bei Mitleidens wert. Ich meine, man man sieht da wieder sehr schön, wie das oft bei solchen Tech-Konferenzen halt läuft. Ja, also es wird einfach mit viel äh Buzzwords und und unsere technologischen
begriffen um sich geworfen um irgendwie erstmal so ein Publikum soweit einzuschüchtern, dass sie das Gefühl haben, dass sie das jetzt eigentlich gar nicht so richtig verstehen?
Ja
sich dann nur auf deine Schlussfolgerung konzentrieren soll, ne? Du sagst halt einfach hier alles total kompliziert, aber irre und Geld und überhaupt und so weiter und jetzt glaubt mal genau
das hier, also wo ihr den Rest alles nicht verstanden habt. Und ich glaube, wenn man da hinkommt und das hast du ja im Prinzip getan und das so ein bisschen aufschlüsselt und und sagt so, äh Leute, da ist nix dahinter, ja, der Kaiser hat einfach keine Kleider.
Dann dann kann ich mir durchaus vorstellen, dass sie dir den ganzen Tag äh Bier ausgeben wollen.
Okay, also der.
Tut einfach Not. Also ich finde das wirklich wichtig, ne? Also wir haben eigentlich zu wenig zu wenig davon. So und ich glaube, viele äh ich merke das auch manchmal bei Vortragenden, die dann in so einen Hype,
mit einsteigen und dann diesen selben Sermon äh auch von sich geben, obwohl sie's selbst,
auch nicht verstanden haben. Also das ist ja dann sozusagen noch mal so die nächste Kategorie von Leuten bis einfach du nur noch einen Raum voll hast, wo keiner,
wovon überhaupt die Rede ist, ja, aber alle finden's geil und und dann dann ist also der Wahnsinn wirklich komplett in der Dose. Es ist einfach,
schlimm, schlimm ist das.
Ja, es ist äh also das.
Also eines der wirklich der ganzen der großen Probleme in diesem ganzen Bereich äh IT ist dass die Menschen ähm also.
Die Menschen keine Ahnung haben, ja, aber dass sie vor allem glauben, ähm keine Ahnung für sich selber bekommen zu können.
Ah, nee, Mathe ist mir zu hoch. Nee, IT ist mir zu hoch. Nee, programmieren kann ich nicht, ne? Und das wird den, ich weiß nicht, wann das den Menschen eingebläut wurde.
Dass sie, dass sie das gar nicht verstehen können, ja und das äh ist etwas, was ich jetzt in in den Bereichen meiner Expertise auch sehr, sehr dramatisch finde, weil.
So schwer ist es alles nicht, ja also und vor allem für Menschen, die es verstehen müssen, weil sie irgendwie meinen, sie möchten damit Geld machen oder so. Ähm.
Ja
Das Gute ist, also dadurch, dass die Konferenz ja äh The Next Rap heißt, können sie dann Web drei aber auch überspringen dann irgendwann so, ne. Also ich denke mal, wenn das nächste Web kommt, dann heißt es wahrscheinlich Web sechs,
oder so, einfach um klarzumachen, dass das dazwischen einfach nur so gescheiterte Beta-Versionen waren. Das war gar nicht so ernst gemeint, so ein bisschen wie mit IP V sechs irgendwie,
wurde ja auch übersprungen.
Okay, also den Vortrag kann man sich anschauen, den Vortrag kann man verbreiten. Allerdings was mich sehr ärgert, der ist auf YouTube nicht gelistet, weil,
der eigentlich, also der ist auf YouTube gehostet, aber auf YouTube nicht gelistet, weil diese Konferenz, diese Vorträge eigentlich nur ihren zahlenden Konferenzbesuchenden zugänglich macht.
Und dann habe ich mich da halt eingeloggt. Ich war jetzt kein Zahn da, aber als Speaker hatte ich trotzdem Login, habe dann gesehen, naja okay, ihr hostet auf YouTube. Ich kann's bei mir ähm betten. Also habe ich halt den den das den Vortrag bei mir in in in meinem Blog entbettet, aber wenn man ihn auf YouTube,
sucht, dann findet man ihn nicht, was natürlich den Vortrag jetzt ja nicht zuträglich ist. Insofern ist er auf Verbreitung,
in den sozialen Medien angewiesen, wenn er euch gefällt und ihr anderen Menschen diesen Vortrag empfehlen möchte. Ich persönlich fand ihn jetzt gar nicht so enorm, aber er ist sehr gut angekommen. So, da haben wir noch eine Bitte.
Von unserem Freund Erdgeist. Ähm und zwar,
Der sucht seit langen Jahren etwas. Der sucht seit langen Jahren etwas, seit seit vielen Jahren etwas,
Und zwar aus dem Jahr 1990. Ein multimediales Digitalprodukt aus dem Jahr 1990 und zwar nur das. Also bitte nicht, wenn ihr was Ähnliches habt von einundneunzig.
Egal, will er nicht haben. Er hätte gerne. Die Telefonteilnehmer Gesamtausgabe von neunzehnhundertneunzig.
Die wurde herausgegeben von der Deutschen Postreklame Schrägstrich DT Medien.
Und wurde verbreitet auf wahrscheinlich ungefähr drei bis fünf CD Roms. Wenn ihr das habt,
es wird wahrscheinlich nicht so viele Menschen geben, weil der Ausgabepreis damals irgendwo im Bereich, ich glaube 3.500 D-Mark, also richtiges Geld, ne.
Nicht irgendwie diese inflationsbehafteten
Euro, sondern richtige, richtige deutsche Mark. Ähm deswegen ist nicht davon auszugehen, dass,
man die jetzt bei sich zu Hause findet,
Aber wenn ihr die irgendwo habt ähm oder wenn ihr zum Beispiel in einer Bibliothek arbeitet, die so etwas vielleicht noch vorrätig hat, dann freut der Erdgeist sich ganz besonders über eine Mail an Erdgeist,
CCC DE oder ihr könnt ihn auch kontaktieren unter at Erdgeist seine DMs sind offen,
Und jetzt fragt ihr euch, was will der Mann mit Telefonnummer von 1990? Ganz einfach, der hat alle anderen. Und zwar äh gab es da auf dem,
Camp,
2019 einen schönen Vortrag, den wir auch verlinken von Artur und Erdgeist. Äh über und die haben nämlich das äh das äh Hobby entwickelt, diese alten CD-Rom Dinger.
Äh das Datenformat zu reversen und damit allerhand,
Dinge zu tun, zu machen, denn was diese CD Roms konnten, die konnten die immer nur zu einem Namen eine Telefonnummer geben, aber sie haben den Reverse-Look ab. Du gibst die Telefonnummer ein und kriegst den Namen, haben sie nicht unterstützt
Und damit denen nicht jemand selber noch nachbaut, haben sie mit unterschiedlichsten,
Skurrilitäten versucht, den Datensatz zu verschlüsseln,
und ähm Erdgeist und Artur haben sich das über die Jahre immer angeschaut, haben diese Datensätze, das Format Reverse engineiert und sich dann quasi eine Datenbank gebaut, in der von jedem Jahr diese Telefonteilnehmer Gesamtausgaben drin sind
und dann Analysen über die Zeit zu machen. Da gibt's sehr schöne Beispiele in diesem ähm.
In diesem Vortrag, wo sie dann feststellen, dass früher auch quasi Telefonnummern in einem bestimmten Bereich, die fingen auch gleich an, weil das,
von der alten äh auch sinnvoll war, weil das die Folge der äh der Schaltzentralen quasi war, ja und ähm.
Kann man irgendwie, was weiß ich, äh ne äh Bundesregierung zieht um von Bonn nach Berlin, dann gibt's auf einmal in Bonn einen kompletten Rufnummernblock nicht mehr und Berlin neun wäre das wohl ist, ja,
oder äh was weiß ich äh der der BND kriegt eine neue Niederlassung in Berlin. Auf einmal gibt's neue Telefonnummern und so weiter. Da gibt's sehr schöne Analysen.
Und ähm ja äh im im äh Linuxforum hat mal irgendjemand äh geschrieben,
dass äh und zwar 2tausendneun, dass er dass er diese CDs hätte, ja, weil er bei irgendeinem Unternehmen arbeitet, ähm,
bei einer ERB-Ermittlungsfirma. Ähm na ja und diese Person, falls die hier zuhört, das ist,
Thors
am 9. August 2009, das ist die einzige Person, die uns bekannt ist, die zumindest mal Zugriff auf dieses Objekt hatte und ihr könnt euch ungefähr vorstellen, wie schmerzhaft das ist, wenn man eine fast vollständige Sammlung hat,
ein Objekt fehlt wenn ihr da.
Das ist ganz schlimm für den OCD irgendwie für den Daten-OCD. Ja.
Dem Ammenerdgeist, ja? Telefonteilnehmer Gesamtausgabe von neunzehnhundertneunzig.
Vielleicht kennt ihr auch noch irgend so ein Messi-Nerd, äh der irgendwie ähm seit den 90er Jahren seine Wohnung mit allem möglichen CD rums vollstellt. Vielleicht habt ihr ja mal bei DT Medien gearbeitet oder so oder der Postreklame, irgendjemand wird so was haben oder Bibliotheken, guter äh guter Hinweis auch.
Ne vielleicht äh kennt ihr ja jemand, den ihr könnt oder so äh,
sicher irgendeine Hörerin. Wird was passendes äh finden. Nochmal Telefonteilnehmer, Gesamtausgabe von 1990 und nur die,
Nur die wollen wir haben. Alles andere bitte nicht melden.
Gibt's noch zwei äh also er hat auch noch ein ein Foto von wie die von ich glaube 91 aussieht. Oder?
Ich gucke das gerade, ist.
Zweiundneunzig.
Zweiundneunzig, ja, da kann man die von 92 mal anschauen, das ist also wirklich genau das aus der Stadt und Universitätsbibliothek Frankfurt am Main, hat der liebe Gott das ist so die.
Tele-Auskunft 1188 Telekom-Daten aus erster Hand.
Irre. Okay, also ja genau, danach ist die Suche und ähm die Verzweiflung ist groß. Äh dann war ich noch im im äh im Kino. Ich war auf einer Filmpremiere. Ich war auf ich war geladener Gast auf einer Filmpremiere.
Echt wow.
Allerdings waren da so viele Leute geladen, dass die Premiere gleichzeitig in mehreren Sälen des gleichen Kinos war. Was sich auch bei einer Filmpremiere noch nicht äh erlebt habe,
Und zwar haben wir uns angeschaut von Mark Uwe Kling, die Känguru Verschwörung. Und äh ich sage mal diplomatisch.
Der erste Kängurufilm, der war nicht so schwer zu toppen.
Der zweite wurde aber jetzt von Mark Uwe Kling selber äh Regie als Regisseur begleitet
und war offenbar auch mit einem besseren Budget gesegnet und mit allgemein größerer Handwerkskunst und das war äh durchaus sehr schön. Also,
Sehr viel besser als der erste. Das war allerdings nicht schwer und äh auch richtig gut für also ich denke im im Genre deutsche Komödie sicherlich auch sehr weit oben.
Also keine.
Warum platzierst du das jetzt hier in unserer netzpolitischen äh in unserem netzpolitischen Potpourri?
Weil wir ja hier relativ viel über Verschwörungstheoretiker gesprochen haben und von denen ähm handelt auch äh das Abenteuer äh von Mark Uwe,
und dem Känguru,
Joe und allen, die dabei sind. Unter diese Liesel äh in dieser Sendung. Ja, also es geht um Verschwörungstheoretiker.
Und den Kampf des Kängurus äh gegen eben jene. Und äh das äh die ja hier immer wieder Thema waren und Thema sind äh möchte ich dir mal kurz empfohlen haben.
Basiert das auf ein Buch oder ist das äh eine reine Filmschöpfung?
Das ist also da ich meine, alle Bücher gelesen zu haben, äh ist das äh eine eine,
würde ich sagen eine äh Neuschöpfung, in der einzelne äh Scherzchen aus den Büchern auch drin vorkommen.
Also man spielt Open Schnick. Ja, zum Beispiel.
Aber äh mir wäre jetzt nicht bekannt, dass diese da so das die geschieht diese Geschichte ist nach meiner Kenntnis nicht in den Büchern.
Scheint auch, sage ich mal, ist relativ erkennbar,
Das äh oder auch ich sage mal naheliegend, dass diese Idee äh dem Mark Uwe wahrscheinlich irgendwie so zwanzig 20 kam, darüber mal einen Film zu machen?
Wer so eine Vermutung
ja kann ich auch übrigens hier äh diesen diesen Spinnern von äh diesen diesen äh Corona-Verschwörungstypen da mit ihrem Online-Pranger äh empfehlen. Der Online-Pranger ist übrigens äh relativ week.
Das wir so sagen darf bisher kein kein abbekommen. Trauen die sich immer nicht.
So, dann haben wir noch Tim. Alexa bekommt einen Zweitnamen.
Ja, welchen denn?
Der steht da nicht. Also es es handelt sich hier in diesem Fall um ein sechsjähriges Kind.
Dass äh ein nicht näher genannten Namen trägt, den auch eine weitverbreitete Sprachassistentin hat.
Und ähm das Kind äh war damals war da regelmäßigen regelmäßigen Mobbing und Hänseleien äh,
unterzogen, weil äh der Klägerin immer wieder Befehle erteilt wurden,
Und das hat das Kind äh seelisch äh sehr belastet, weshalb es sich gewünscht hat seinen Namen zu ändern. Er hat das ähm,
hat das äh Moment äh in seiner Heimatstadt hatte das Verwaltungsgericht gesagt, nein, dann hat sie ins,
äh oder nee, die Verwaltung hat gesagt, nein, dann ist sie für das Verwaltungsgericht gezogen und darf jetzt einen Zweitnamen bekommen und den kann man ja dann auch einfach als Rufname verwenden und damit
heißt das Kind dann nicht mehr so, kann sich quasi einen legalen äh zweiten Rufnamen zu setzen. Ich kenne eine Siri und zwei Alexen,
Und ich kann nur sagen, die ich glaube, die sind auch, also die waren jahrelang mit ihren Namen zufrieden, ne. Aber wenn du dich eben als Siri vorstellst.
Dann ist der Witz einfach aufm Tisch. Also.
Und es ist auch so und es ist so also als ich Siri kenne, kenne ich jetzt nicht besonders gut, aber sonst auch sehr, ich bin Simon und ich auch so habe ich nur so gequält geguckt und sie auch so, ja das war also selbst das kannst du nicht vermeiden, ja? Es ist äh.
Ja wie auch? Also ich meine, das ist schon ganz schön äh frech eigentlich,
meine Alexa ist insofern sogar noch die schlechtere Wahl,
Weil es ja irgendwie ein klarer Frauenname ist. Also wir haben jetzt zumindest nicht bekannt, dass Jungs irgendwie Alexa genannt werden.
Na vor allem ist Alexa ein verbreiteter Name. Äh also ich glaube, wenn man jetzt die die Quote von Alexen und Sieren äh sich in in Deutschland, USA oder der Welt anzeigt, werden die Sieren noch sehr viel äh seltener sein als die Alex.
Nee, da liegst du glaube ich falsch, weil Siri ist ja ist in Indien einfach extrem verbreitet.
Und es halt auch ein Name, der sowohl für also meistens wohl für Frauen, aber auch für Männer äh vergeben wird. Und ja.
Skandinavischer Name äh kurz vorm von Sigrid.
Keine Ahnung, warum der in Indien äh so beliebt sein soll.
Ähm.
Thai, in Thai ist es ein neutraler Name.
Indien Feminine, also in Indien ein Frauenname? Äh in Thai ein geschlechtsneutraler Name.
In in der englischsprachigen Wikipedia spezifisch als Skandinavisch hervorgehoben.
Na ja, egal. Also,
Beides äh beides auf jeden Fall also es ist schon glaube ich dramatisch, wenn du einen Namen trägst und der dir dann von Google oder Apple kaputt gemacht wird und es auch tragisch, dass es irgendwo so ein so ein irgend so ein so ein,
Typen bei bei der Verwaltung gibt, der sagt, nee, du darfst den Namen nicht ändern, Siri. Man ey. Ja, okay.
Also er wird hier auch als ja als indischer Name in drei Regionen, in drei Regionen, Indiens als sehr populär.
Der drei Regionen Indiens ist äh wenig von Indien, aber sehr viele Menschen wahrscheinlich.
Ja ja, genau.
Okay.
Also so oder so ist das ist das natürlich ein echtes äh Problem und ähm auch nichts was sich nachträglich noch in irgendeiner Form ja,
ändern lässt, ne. Ich meine klar, wenn du jetzt noch jung bist, dann hast du noch eine Chance nochmal durchzustarten vielleicht so ein gewisser Hinsicht. Aber für Leute, die schon länger unterwegs sind, äh ist das natürlich schwierig.
Ja. So, dann.
Geht es weiter mit einem Hack des CCC. Und zwar haben wir ja im Rahmen der der Modernisierung des Digitalstandorts Deutschland,
ja? Hat man sich ja überlegt, ey wie können wir Menschen,
Online identifizieren mit Hilfe ihres elektronischen Personalausweises, ja? Auf dem seit über zehn Jahren, also jetzt inzwischen,
in allen gültigen Personalausweisen. Ja, eine Smartcut ist, die die E-ID-Funktion unterstützt, wo du mit der Ausweis-App dich remote überall
authentifizieren kannst, ja? Theoretisch sogar Dokumente signieren kannst, E-ID und so weiter, alle diese Funktionalitäten, wie können wir.
In diesem Land, wo es das gibt, etwas kaputt machen. Wie können wir was maximal dummes machen?
Und das hat natürlich nicht lange gedauert, bis man sich gesagt hat, wir machen ein Video-Ident.
Ja, das heißt, du hast eine sichere Smart Card, ja, mit einer Signatur der Bundesrepublik Deutschland, die sagt, es handelt sich hierbei um ein echtes Ausweisdokument, die du mit jedem NFC-Reader prüfen kannst, ja, wunderbare Erfindung.
Und um deren Echtzeit zu prüfen.
Setzt du auf eine Webcam mit 720 P wo die Leute dann an ihrem Ausweis wackeln müssen.
Und am anderen Ende sitzt in der Regel, wenn es ein Mensch ist, äh habe,
das Verfahren ja auch das eine oder andere Mal genutzt, ähm waren das in der Regel hatte ich den Eindruck, ja, also aufgrund meiner meines Samples würde ich schätzen, dass sich das Callcenter am anderen Ende,
eher östlich von Frankfurt an der Oder befindet,
Ähm das aber auch unerheblich, weil dass dieses Verfahren zu überlisten ist, wurde schon vor einigen Jahren gezeigt.
Also haben sich irgendwelche Leute gedacht, ey wie können wir das denn jetzt mal noch noch innovativer machen ja.
Lass mal die Menschen wegmachen, weil das ist ja digitaler Prozess. Wir machen am anderen Ende eine KI.
Da sitzt gar kein Mensch mehr, sondern eine KI. So und die die prüft.
Mittels Kamera deinen Ausweis und sage dir dann, ob der echt ist oder nicht.
Wer das mal gemacht hat, weiß ähm der die Sicherheit dieses Verfahrens äh über das über das Video hängt
primär an zwei Aspekten. Einmal daran, dass man den Ausweis an dem Ausweis wackeln soll,
um die darin enthaltenen hier Hologramme eben aufblinken zu lassen, ja.
Und einmal daran, dass man mit äh also mit der Hand vor dem Ausweis mit den Fingern davor durch soll. Also du spreizt quasi deine Finger und wackelst vor dem Ausweis, ja? Ähm,
Das dient also bei erste Teil zeigt mal die Hologramme. Der ist eigentlich relativ einfach,
mit einem mit einem Videoprogramm live da reinzuändern, ja? Wo du einfach sagst, alles klar, wir tracken hier ein Objekt und wenn das Objekt sich so oder so dreht, dann lassen wir lassen wir so ein bisschen Hologramm äh Firlefanz drüberflackern. Ähm der Teil mit dem,
äh Finger davor kreisen lassen, ist halt dann ein bisschen schwieriger, weil du dann sehr genau erkennen musst, also dein deine deine,
Videosoftware, die dir da den falschen Ausweis hinrändert. Muss ein sehr muss sehr genau erkennen, wo jetzt grade Finger vor dem Ausweis ist und wo nicht. So.
Problem, das grundsätzliche Problem löst du dadurch, dass du einfach einen sehr hohen Kontrast machst zwischen deiner Hand und deinem Fake-Ausweis, ja?
In diesem Fall hat Martin, der den Hack gemacht hat, einfach seine Hand eingefärbt. Ja, also der hat,
Hand der Hand eine sehr ein sehr starke rote Farbe gegeben,
Sie sich sehr genau von diesem Ausweis abgrenzt, damit dieser Renderer sehr genau quasi den Ausweis und die da von der sich davor bewegenden Hand trennen kann und hat dann nachher einfach in der in der Livebildbearbeitung,
die Hand wieder mit einem Grünschleier überlegt, dann überlegt, damit sie wieder wie Hautfarbe aussah. Ne, also alles Rote wurde am Ende im am Ende geränderten in Hautfarbe getauscht,
seine Hand war rot, die er dann eben vor diesem Ausweis bewegt hat. So damit ist es äh Martin gelungen sechs von diesen äh Anbietern zu überlisten und sich wieder allerhand äh Ausweisdokumente äh und Anmeldungen überall,
zu verschaffen und ja,
ich mir ist unvorstellbar, wie man damit nicht rechnen konnte und mir es auch unvorstellbar, wie man in wie irgendjemand das,
für ein innovatives Verfahren halten kann, ja? Also und noch mal, ne? Das ist ein Ausweis, der hat eine Smartcard drin. Es gibt diese Ausweis-App zwei, also es ist alles da.
Es ist alles da.
Ja, aber das heißt ja nicht, dass man das halt gleich nutzen muss.
Nicht gleich, aber zehn, elf, 12 Jahre später kann man das kann man mit anfangen.
Aber Linus, das ist ein bisschen zu einfach.
Außerdem förderst du den Markt. Ja, Start einer Start-ups, die äh Videoidentifikation mache.
Stimmt, Digital first bedenken second.
Genau, da können können viele unterbezahlte Menschen in ihren Wohnzimmern, auch während der Pandemie, anderer Leute Personalausweise einsehen.
Die Gematik hat äh das äh hat die Nutzung dieses Videoverfahrens für die Thematikinfrastruktur unmittelbar nach der Veröffentlichung,
untersagt und ähm es gibt dann noch ein äh ja ein Kommentar äh auf Heise,
dem ich mich jetzt inhaltlich nicht so sehr anschließen würde, indem gesagt wird, ja also Verfahren haben äh Restunsicherheiten, ja, das ist grundsätzlich erstmal korrekt, aber.
Ey Leute, es geht um Ausweis, weißt du? Also das, wo du wo dieses Verfahren zur einen zum Einsatz kommt, ne? Das sind ja genau die Aspekte Gesundheitswesen.
Und Geldwäsche
Ja das sind die, das sind die Dinge, wo wo es wirklich auf wo's einmal wirklich für wo eine falsche Identifizierung als jemand anders wirklich katastrophal ist, ja. Äh ein anderes Beispiel, was Martin noch gezeigt hat, ist so Glücksspiel
Ja gut, ne, wenn jetzt irgendwie so ein so ein 16-jähriger irgendwie spielsüchtig ist oder so und die Kohle von jemand anders verzockt, kann man noch sagen, na ja okay,
ne, aber Gesundheitswesen und ähm.
Banken, die vertrauen ausgerechnet auf so eine bekloppten Methode, ne. Das ist schon wirklich,
dramatisch tragisch und und auch so peinlicher, so äh zeigen sie doch ihren Ausweis. Können sie Licht anmachen, ist so dunkel bei ihnen. Äh es ist so.
Aber ist modern, weil ist mit Internet. Also wie wie wenn jemals und und das aber also um's noch wir haben jetzt lange genug über dieses Verfahren gelacht, ne? Der Punkt ist natürlich, dass sie,
diese Identifizierungsanbieter nehmen natürlich pro Identifizierungsvorgang einen Betrag, ja und der ist einfach geringer als Postident, beziehungsweise,
Abbruchquote ist geringer als Post-Ident. Postident ist ja, glaube ich, auch ein Anbieter davon, ja. Äh,
Ne? Früher hat man äh die Post quasi die die Prüfung angeboten, dann kommst du mit deinem Ausweis zur Post. Dann haben die den Ausweis geprüft. Übrigens auch nur nach Augenschein, das ist auch die Argumentation in diesem Heisekommentar.
Ja, dass der dann nur nach Augenschein geprüft wurde und das ist aber genau das, was was seit zehn Jahren nicht mehr sein müsste, ja? Dass du,
Dass du einen Ausweis nach Augenschein prüfst. Da habe ich ja vor Jahren schon, erzähle ich öfter, als ich auf der Konferenz der Geldrucker war.
War eine geile Konferenz. Da wäre ich gerne mal wieder eingeladen. Da sind die Leute, die Geld drucken, kannst du dir vorstellen, was das für eine Party ist, ne? So und die die also die sich mit kunstvollen Druckverfahren auseinandersetzen,
unfälschbar sind. Und jedes Mal, wenn die dir zeigt, das hier ist ein unfälschbares Hologramm,
Du sagst, ja, wie kann das denn unfälschbar sein, wenn du in der Lage bist, das herzustellen,
Merken die nicht, ne? So kryptografische Signaturen, dass man damit wirklich was machen kann, ist sich zu denen durchgedrungen. Also.
Es ist wirklich sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr traurig.
Na ja, okay, also Video-Ident ist kaputt. Ich bin mal gespannt, was sie sich da jetzt einfallen lassen. Ähm natürlich hat so eine Veröffentlichung auch immer hm ein bisschen neben, also in Anführungszeichen unerwünschte Nebeneffekte, weil,
Identifizierung, ich werde ja nicht müde, das zu betonen.
Oft etwas gegen deinen Willen. Ja, also du möchtest eigentlich, dass das nicht oft stattfindet und du möchtest, dass es äh oder oder sagen wir nicht, nicht unbedingt gegen deinen Willen, aber gegen gegen dich. Ja, wenn du dich irgendwo,
sicher, identifiziv wenn du irgendwo sicher identifiziert wurdest, kommst du aus der Nummer auch nicht mehr raus. Also willst du,
dass das potenziell A ein sicheres Verfahren ist,
B gerne auch so ein ganz kleines bisschen umständlich, damit du nicht überall die ganze Zeit identifiziert wirst und ähm dann natürlich,
am Ende sicher, ja und mit diesem Videoident hast du leider genau den falschen Trade off. Es ist unsicher und es wird ähm viel gemacht,
Dadurch hast du am Ende ebene nicht wünschenswerte äh Situationen.
Vielleicht sollte man nochmal kurz äh drauf verweisen, wie wir uns das äh eigentlich wünschen. So, ich meine, der,
Personalausweis ist eben schon mit der entsprechenden Sicherheitstechnik äh ausgestattet und alles, was es quasi braucht, sind NFC-Lesegeräte, sodass ein,
Gerät, was man selber in der Hand hält, zuverlässig die Verbindung elektronisch zu diesen Dokument herstellen kann und,
über die kryptographischen Methoden, die Teil dieses Protokolls sind, einem dritten gegenüber sicherstellen kann
hier ein Ausweis vorliegt und dass die angegebenen Daten da auch genauso abrufbar sind und dass
in dem Moment, wo sie jetzt hier über das Internet an den Anbieter übertragen werden, auch tatsächlich von einem echten Personalausweis kommen. Das ist ja das, was man eigentlich sicherstellen möchte. Und das ist halt
ab dem Moment machbar, wo man eben über ein entsprechendes NFC-Lesegerät äh verfügt,
und das hat natürlich noch nicht jeder, aber in Form der Smartphones ist das eben jetzt ähm.
Noch nicht genauso verbreitet wie Webcams. Ja, aber in zunehmenden Maße und dann muss man eben diesen ganzen Affentanz gar nicht erst machen.
So ist es, ja und das ist also Anna hatte dazu sehr schön ähm kommentiert, Video-Ident, eingestürzte Brückentechnologie und Brückentechnologie ist glaube ich ein sehr sehr schöner ähm Begriff, ne.
So wie Erdgas.
Ist auch eine Brückentechnologie.
Brückentechnologie, die uns äh.
Danach? Diese?
Gucken wir mal was wir als nächstes kriegen. Bisher waren das immer nur so Halbzeiten Angebote. Na ja. Ach so ja äh grauer Wasserstoff.
Diese ja ja.
Also mit diesen Wasserstofffarben, das habe ich noch nicht ganz raus. Grün und blau weiß ich, aber.
Muss ja auch produziert werden. Den kannst du ja nicht,
irgendwie so am Strand einsammeln so, aber er wird halt äh derzeit auch noch unter Einsatz fossiler Energien sozusagen als Abfallprodukt der industriellen Prozesse, der Petro äh chemischen Industrie hergestellt,
dass sozusagen du zwar Wasserstoff hast, aber der ist halt nicht grün, weil er eben
selber wiederum in seiner Erzeugung CO2 freisetzt, weil äh Teil der petrochemischen Industrie.
Äh nur mit grünem Wasserstoff, also Wasserstoff
bei dem kein CO2 noch zusätzlich freigesetzt wird, kannst du dann auch die entsprechenden Effekte haben, dass wenn du diesen Wasserstoff wieder zum Antrieb von,
Schiffen oder Flugzeugen oder in der Industrie, im äh in der Stahlproduktion zur Anwendung bringst, dass du dann eben auch wirklich CO2-neutral bist. Nur dass es halt derzeit einfach noch nicht genug Kapazität,
gibt ausreichende Mengen Wasserstoff,
auf die grüne Methode herzustellen. Und das äh äh fuhre aber jetzt in den letzten Jahren, natürlich auch von der ähm,
Industrie halt so ja hier Wasserstoff total nehmt mal Wasserstoff voll geile Idee ey.
Warte mal, gibt's wirklich nicht genug Kapazitäten, weil man hört doch eigentlich die ganze Zeit, dass Windpark Solaranlagen und so weiter teilweise zu Peak.
Aus dem Wind genommen werden,
Um weil sie gerade zu viel liefern, also mehr als gebraucht wird, kann man da nicht dann dynamisch äh Elektrolyse machen und ähm Wasserstoff äh produzieren?
Ja könnte man, aber das muss dann halt auch mehr oder weniger vor Ort äh getan werden und das muss dann gespeichert.
Ah, das knallt immer. Das knallt immer.
Werden, also da hängt eine riesige logistische Kette dran, so ähnlich wie Tankstelleninfrastruktur ja auch nicht einfach so per Schnipp
da war, sondern eben über Jahrzehnte äh in diesen Zustand gebracht wurde, den wir heute so als selbstverständlich ansehen. Ähm.
Grünes Diesel kennen wir ja alle. Grünes Diesel Camp ja alle. Nicht mehr wegzudenken.
Also langfristig perspektivisch sicherlich klar so, aber wenn du halt jetzt mal schaust, wo brauchen wir den denn und in welchen Mengen
Du nimmst einfach mal nur die Stahlindustrie, dann ist das schon so sehr viel mehr als derzeit auch nur ansatzweise produziert wird. So dass klar ist, dass das eben kein leichter Weg ist. Das muss jetzt einfach.
Okay, dann machen wir einfach.
Nach oben.
Ich würde sagen, wir machen äh bis dahin einfach äh Video-Wasserstoff. So wir haben äh es gibt neue Cyber Crime.
Lass uns lass uns lieber erstmal ein Video, ein ein Video Identifizierungsverfahren für die Politik machen. Die müssen bei uns anrufen per Webcam,
uns ihre Ideen erzählen, was sie jetzt sozusagen als Nächstes vorhaben und dann gucken wir mal. Da müssen sie ein bisschen wackeln in der Kamera,
uns unsere Ideen übermitteln. Das wären auch feststellen können, dass es auch gute Ideen sind und wenn das halt nicht klappt, dann ja.
Franziska Giffey kann man von sowas leicht überzeugen und die hat sich.
Die hat auch voll. Ja, meinst du, die lässt sich verarschen von irgendjemanden, der anruft und sagt, ey wer Wladimir Klitschko? Die hat natürlich auch vorher Video-Ident gemacht mit dem. Locker.
Ja ja.
Das wurde jetzt, glaube ich, auch noch veröffentlicht, ne? Das waren ja irgendwelche Komiker, denen das jetzt auch veröffentlicht hat. Siehst du, ich glaube, das könnte.
Keine ahnen können, dass man Vladimir Klitschko dort spricht.
Oh Mann ey warte, also Franziska Giffey, ne?
Man muss jetzt zugute halten, sie ist beinahe nicht die einzige, die darauf reingefallen.
Giffey ist in in Paris ja fast fast von einem E-Bike überfahren worden.
Ach, wirklich. Wow, vom Bullerblühfahrrad.
Deswegen, deswegen ist sie von der Verkehrswende nicht überzeugt.
Zu gefährlich.
Alter,
Ich bin fast vom E-Bike überfahren worden. So ja, sei froh, dass du nicht fast vom LKW überfahren wurdest. Der überfährt dich nämlich wirklich. Also es ist,
auch wirklich weißt du, wenn du wenn die was sagen und du du musst schon so so du hörst das im Radio, weißt du stehst morgens auf, hörst das im Radio und sagst Mann hey natürlich so ist doch ich möchte Politikerinnen und Politiker wo das ähm,
wo ich wo ich ausgewogenere Reaktionen habe.
Zum Beispiel äh tatsächlich muss man auch mal an dieser Stelle, wenn wir jetzt hier schon eh über alles reden, was uns interessiert und die Hörerin nicht. Robert Habeck,
Ganz großes Instagram Instagram Game.
Der äh jetzt erklärt da die Politik und die Lage und äh was er was die Regierung erreicht hat, was sie hätte erreichen wollen, was die Herausforderungen sind und so.
Das ist wirklich äh schon sehr beeindruckend, was der was der macht. In der Kommunikation. Ihr habt eine unabhängig jetzt von der also wie er,
Einfach mal die Zeit nimmt, in Ruhe die Hintergründe sei der Herausforderung, an denen sein Ministerium arbeitet zu schildern und äh selbstkritisch zu äh bewerten. Das ist schon sehr äh beeindruckend.
Das ist auch nötig. Also denke die komplexe Zeit,
erfordern einfach auch etwas äh Hintergrundinformation und man kann sich nicht einfach immer nur in Parolen und und lächelnden Aussagen ähm beschränken. So das das Modell ist einfach abgelaufen. Ich denke, so ein bisschen mehr ähm,
Hintergrund angereicherte Entscheidungswegfindung ist äh ein sinnvoller Weg. Machen wir ja auch ein bisschen.
Alles bei uns abgeguckt.
So Cyber Crime. Cyber Crime problem. Es gibt.
Was ist mit Schabba Shabbat Crime in in Deutschland?
Ja, also einmal ähm gibt es den den Bericht der Auswirkungen von Covid-19 auf die Kriminalitätslage in Deutschland, veröffentlicht vom Bundeskriminalamt.
Ja und in den den hat das äh Bundeskriminalamt veröffentlicht und äh haben dann zum Beispiel gesagt ähm,
Weniger Wohnungseinbrüche, klar,
Wirklich einfach große Konjunkturflaute, wenn alle zu Hause sind, ne? Da musst du halt auf äh bewaffneten Raubüberfall umschulen oder äh weniger Einbrüche machen, ja also Einbrüche gab's weniger.
Und dann sagen Sie äh in der Pressemitteilung behauptet das BKA dann, dass,
äh die durch die pandemiebedingte Beschleunigung der Digitalisierung oder aus das so äh.
Ich merke, ne, wie wie so eine beschleunigte Digitalisierung über dieses Land hereinbrach, ne, über also Fake News, Fake News, das ist ja schon so, also das.
Also geht dir das nicht auch so, dass wenn du auf die Straße trittst, dass du von so einem Sog der Digitalisierung fast auf die Straße.
Ja, das ist wie im also das ist ich sehe hier auch die ganze Zeit diese ähm wasserstoffgetriebenen Raketenbagger,
vergraben, ne, von Porsche sind die, die hat der Christian Lindner von Porsche bekommen ähm scheiß, also beschleunigt die Digitalisierung, da weißt du schon Quatsch, ja? Aber,
hätte es Gelegenheiten für Straftaten im Zusammenhang mit der Darstellung sexualisierter Gewalt gegen Kinder und sexuellen Missbrauch von Kindern ermöglich.
Und dann sagen sie, äh dass bereits seit Jahren zu der bereits seit Jahren zu beobachtende Trend steigender Fallzahlen,
hat sich in beiden Bereichen während der Pandemie noch einmal verstärkt. So, dann wissen wir, diese Statistik, ja, traut keiner Statistik, die du nicht selber gefälscht hast. Markus Reuter, schaut sich das dann nämlich mal an und sagt, richtig, iss,
die erfassten Fälle in der polizeilichen Kriminalitätsstatistik seit Jahren deutlich steigen. Doch.
Das liegt natürlich äh ein daran, dass es verstärkte,
Aufhellung, also verstärkte und sehr viel bessere äh Polizeiarbeit in diesem Bereich gibt, ja? Und wenn du davon ausgehst, was ja was ja auch keiner unbedingt bestreitet, dass es ein Dunkelfeld gibt, potenziell sogar ein sehr großes, ja und du hast,
du du unternimmst stärkere Anstrengungen das Dunkelfeld aufzuhellen, dann,
nimmt natürlich die Erfassung und Verfolgung solcher Straftaten in deiner Statistik zu und das ist gut bis zu dem Moment, wo es kein Dunkelfeld mehr gibt.
Oder die Entdeckmaßnahmen ähm
sinken, obwohl deine Anstaltungen hochgehen, weil das bedeutet natürlich, dass dann oder da wäre eine gute Erklärung dafür, dass die gesamte Anzahl der Verbrechen äh rückläufig ist. Das heißt, das nun mehr erfasst wird, liegt an der besseren Polizeiarbeit.
Ja? Und nicht daran, dass es irgendwie Covid-19 gab. Ähm,
So, also Markus Reuter schreibt hier auch noch mal, das heißt konkret, dass nicht die Anzahl der pädokriminellen Taten an sich steigt, sondern immer mehr Täterinnen ins Visier von Ermittlungen geraten.
Das sagt auch das BKA,
Allerdings erst in der längeren Fassung dieser Statistik auch diese verlinkt, äh die natürlich deutlich weniger Menschen lesen und wenn man jetzt mal schaut, wer sind denn deutlich weniger Menschen. Ähm Markus schreibt dann nachher in einem Update.
Die irreführende Pressemitteilung des BKA wurde von n-tv DPA und Redaktionsnetzwerk Deutschland übernommen. Die DPA hat die Meldung dann korrigiert und um einen Hinweis ergänzt. Aber ja, so so schnell, ja.
Hast du entsprechende falsche Interpretation von Statistik in in der Welt.
Und äh dann gibt es noch den äh Bericht der Bundesregierung,
über die im Jahr 2021 ergriffenen Maßnahmen zum Zweck der Löschung von Telemedienangeboten mit,
kinderpornografischen Inhalt im Sinne des Paragraphen184 B des Strafgesetzbuchs.
Ich glaube, es seit vielen Jahren eigentlich Usus,
von dokumentierten Genesis vorzusprechen aber in diesem Dokument ist das eben nun mal der Titel, deswegen habe ich den jetzt mal korrekt äh zitiert und da kommen sie eigentlich zu dem Ergebnis.
Dass bei denen in Deutschland gehosteten Inhalten ähm,
97,5 Prozent der Gemeldeten innerhalb äh der gemeldeten innerhalb von einer Woche nach der Meldung äh gelöscht wurden. Äh zweiundsechzig Prozent äh schon nach zwei Tagen nach dem Hinweis,
verbleibenden,
äh zweieinhalb Prozent, die nach einer Woche nicht gelöscht sind waren Gründe bei denen aus ermittlungstaktischen Gründen auf die Löschung verzichtet wird, also,
könnte man jetzt davon ausgehen, dass dann vielleicht der Hoster mit den Ermittlungsbehörden zusammenarbeitet. Wir wissen bisher hat das BKA so etwas nicht getan.
Ähm also wir stellen eigentlich fest, dass dieses, ne, Löschen statt Sperren äh sehr gut äh funktioniert und das BKA hat hier eine äh.
Etwas komische Rolle. Ich habe habe mir das auch tatsächlich noch mal im Innenministerium erklären lassen. Es war auch einleuchtend. Ja oder nachvollziehbar.
Wenn jemand einen Hinweis gibt an den Hoster, ja, dann hat dieser dann ist das ein Hinweis.
Dieser Hinweis hat natürlich jetzt erstmal nicht unbedingt ähm also wenn der jetzt von mir kommt.
Ist das potenziell etwas anderes, als wenn der vom BKA kommt
weil vom BKA ist es ja ne als Behörde macht oder als Ermittlungsbehörde äh im Rahmen Gefahrenabwehr und so weiter,
Hätte die einen sehr großen Papieraufwand jetzt eine Löschung anzuordnen, aber das ist ja offenbar auch überhaupt nicht notwendig, weil sie nur hinweisen muss.
Ja? Also der einfache Hinweis des BKAs äh ist natürlich für die für die Hoster ausreichend. Genauso äh wie der einfache Hinweis eines äh jeden anderen.
Ja ähm die Geschichte damals, wo Daniel Moosbrucker äh Unmengen an Terabyte hat löschen lassen, die über Boiston verlinkt waren. Wir haben es hier mehrmals besprochen, insbesondere auch im äh Kontext Chatkontrolle.
Äh da hat das BKA auch das nicht getan und es gibt trotzdem keinen Grund, äh insbesondere vor dieser Meldung jetzt kein Grund zu der Annahme, dass das BKA das damals nicht auch hätte tun können, ja?
Ja das also die ähm.
Die Rolle des BKS hier einfach unklar und beziehungsweise sagen wir mal, das BKA sagt, sie haben.
Sie hätten keine Rechtsgrundlage, Löschung anzuordnen und dann ist aber der andere Punkt, Sie müssen und Sie sehen sich deswegen auch nicht für zuständig gleichzeitig. Also da ist irgendwie hin und her, die nun veröffentlichte Studie zeigt
machst du Hinweis, ist das Material weg? Das kann man dem BKA äh abverlangen. Das ist nicht zu viel verlangt und ähm
Nancy Fesa sagt ja auch, dass die Entfernung dieser Darstellung höchste Priorität für das BKA hätte, also kann das BKR ja vielleicht einfach mal auf die Dienstherren hören,
Schritt weiter aber wie gesagt eigentlich oft hier beklagte Missstand,
scheint einfach nicht äh vorhanden zu sein. Und das ist ja einer der Missstände, die eben für die Chatkontrolle äh herangeführt wird.
Die übrigens von den EU-Datenschutzbehörden äh,
stark kritisiert wird, zumindest der Vorschlag der Kommission. Äh wo also die äh EU-Datenschützerin sagen, sie zweifeln an der Verhältnismäßigkeit und daran, ob sie überhaupt helfen würde, ja?
Weiterhin waren sie vor eben anlassloser Massenüberwachung. Ja richtig,
ja die Fehlerquoten sind das Problem, man sucht an der falschen Stelle. Wir haben das hier in dieser Sendung oft genug erklärt. Ich habe den das Thema nur noch mal reingenommen, um dieses Wissen aufzufrischen und daran zu erinnern, dass das eines der
allerwichtigsten Themen ist, äh die wir grade äh in Deutschland in diesem Jahr zu behandeln haben.
Und das hat auch ein ähm Vater gemerkt, äh der in der Story der New York Times mag, heißt,
Mark wohnt in San Francisco, hatte hat einen Säugling und äh dieser Säugling hatte Schmerzen.
Und zwar hatte der Säugling diese Schmerzen im Genitalbereich. Und war Freitagabend, deswegen,
hart äh die Frau dann ein ein Krankenhaus angerufen hat irgendwie ein äh versucht einen Notarzt hin also einen Notfalltermin im Krankenhaus zu bekommen und die ähm.
Die äh,
Also die äh Ansprechperson im Krankenhaus, äh der Assistent des Arztes oder was auch immer, ja, hat dann gesagt, okay, schick doch schon mal ein Bild, ja?
Dann äh kann äh die Doktorin sich schon mal darauf vorbereiten und äh so, weil das scheint ja schlimm zu sein, gehen die Teilschmerzen beim Säugling sind genauso schlimm wie Genitalschmerzen bei Erwachsenen, nur dass der Säugling halt echt nichts dafür kann, ja? Äh
oder äh oder äh nichts dagegen machen kann, nichts dafür, weiß ich nicht. Ähm so, also nimmt er sein Android-Foto, macht ein Foto.
Und wird dann von äh Google ähm.
Gepflegt, als jemand, der äh Child Sexual Sexual Appuse Material in seiner in seinen Google Fotos hat.
Also genau das, wovon wir von der Chatkontrolle die ganze Zeit reden, ja, dass Kontext unabhängig diese Bilder eben,
problematisch erscheinen können und ein Bild von einer ne von einem verletzten Genital eines Säuglings,
kann natürlich in dem einen Kontext auf sehr schweren Missbrauch hinweisen,
und in diesem anderen Kontext auf eine Notsituation, in der die Eltern gerade alles für ihr Kind tun,
Und dieser Kontext ist in dem Bild einfach nicht zu erkennen. Und genau aus diesem Grund ist diese Technologie eben auch äh so ein Problem, ja?
Beziehungsweise das Scannen privater Informationen auf äh Servern, mit äh künstlicher Intelligenz sogenannter, also mit Machine Learning.
Wo ähm ja wie wir ja wissen, Algorithmen eingesetzt werden, dessen genaues Verhalten man in dem Sinne überhaupt nicht vorhersagen kann, weil sie ja im Prinzip versuchen unbekannt ist zu erkennen,
auf Basis von dem, was ihn bisher bekannt geworden ist und da hängt es halt immer sehr davon ab, wie und womit trainierst du so etwas,
und äh ja, dann kannst du halt solche und solche Ergebnisse haben und dann ist irgendwie relativ,
unüberraschend, dass äh in diesem Falle so eine Automatik zu solchen Schlüssen kommt,
Auch weitere Automatiken anstößt, bis hin zu jetzt wirst du ja auch digital verurteilt und du bist jetzt irgendwie böse.
Jetzt gibt's aber noch einen wichtigen Hinweis, ja, nicht nur Automatiken, denn hier äh hat dann auch ein menschlicher Content Moderator von Google.
Das Foto angeschaut, also erst sagt die AI, ey hier ist was, ja? Dann kommt, genau wie in der Chatkontrolle vorgeschlagen, ein Mensch und sagt, jo und dann ist äh passiert äh der Account wurde gesperrt,
und mach die Person wurde gemeldet an die Cyber-Tiplein vom ja also genau das was ähm,
die ähm was die Chatkontrolle machen möchte, nur dass es nicht der Snack Mac ist, sondern dann auch noch irgendwie eine Neuropol.
Das ist hier passiert und auch diese menschliche Prüfung,
ist passiert. Und nochmal das Schlimme ne, ob's ob's ob's die AI macht oder ein Mensch, es ist in fast schon unerheblich, weil beide den gleichen Fehler machen, nämlich hier.
Ein Bild zu,
In einen anderen Kontext zu nehmen und oder eine Entscheidung zu treffen über ein Bild, das in einem anderen Kontext sicherlich geeignet wäre.
Bei Pädokriminellen äh für bestimmte Zwecke zu dienen. Hier aber nicht und das ist am Bild einfach nicht erkennbar,
Und deswegen kann es weder eine AI noch ein Mensch, noch sonst jemand, ja und der gute Mark hat jetzt sein Google-Account weg.
Gut, ich wäre froh, endlich mal auf Google zu sein, aber ich vermute, dass es für ihn nicht ganz so unterhaltsam ist.
Und äh äh Google hat also zumindest ähm.
Das Spannende ist, dass die Polizei den Sachverhalt ja aufgeklärt hat, ja, also die Polizei glaubt ihm, Google nicht. Was ist jetzt noch schlimmer macht, ja, also der hatte den Ärger mit der Polizei, okay.
Polizei hat gesagt, ja okay, sehen wir ein, ne. Hoffen wir, dass das da alles hier wieder in Ordnung wird. Man hat ja wenigstens an der an der an der Polizeifrontruhe,
Aber immer noch sein Google-Account nicht wieder, weil Google sagt, nee, nee, pass auf, da verhandeln wir gar nicht. Mit solchen Leuten verhandeln wir gar nicht.
Alter Vater. Ja also das.
Support zu kriegen bei Google, das ist äh quasi unmöglich.
Kannst du eine E-Mail schreiben. Ähm ja also okay genau also ne ich glaube ist klar, genau das. Genau dieser Prozess, der dann jetzt hier bald ähm.
Angeordnet äh millionenfach stattfinden soll oder oder milliardenfach täglich diese Prüfung, wenn da eben ein solcher
Fall. Das ist genau der Fall, vor dem gewarnt wird und dass es hier genau mit dem gleichen Prozess abgebildet. Also genau dieses
äh dieser Ablauf ähm sollte in den Chatkontrolle-Debatten äh regelmäßig wiederholt werden. Ja,
So sieht's aus. Nächstes Thema Tim oder willst du noch was zu sagen?
Ähm,
Ja, ich meine, die Debatte hatten wir ja äh schon mal. Da geht's ja äh wild hin und her, ähm welche Techniken hier zum Einsatz kommen sollen oder nicht,
was halt jetzt hier Google zum Einsatz gebracht hat, ist eben äh eine Methode, die halt einfach die Privatsphäre schon heute äh komplett missachtet. Also das sind sozusagen genau diese Automatiken bereits längst scharf geschaltet,
jenseits einer europäischen politischen Lösung, sondern das,
ist schon da. Ja, also da wird zwar nicht dein Chat äh also der Chat wird vielleicht auch kontrolliert, das weiß ich jetzt nicht, ne? Aber das ist ja hier im Prinzip eine Fotoalbum äh Kontrolle.
Ne, also da macht sozusagen Google den ganzen Tag Diaabend bei dir und äh denkt sich was.
Also was was in auf der EU-Ebene jetzt natürlich gerade diskutiert wird, was man so hört, ist ähm,
Das einige schon verstanden haben,
dass das mit der automatisierten Erkennung neuen Materials wahrscheinlich eine ziemlich schlechte Idee ist. Weshalb einige schon argumentieren, sie wollen äh sich mit der,
Erkennung ähm von bereits bekanntem Material zufriedengeben?
Dazu zwei Dinge. Das Genital von Marx Kind gehört durch die Meldung an zum bekannten Material. Das heißt, die Ärztin ist als nächstes dran.
Nummer eins und ähm ja und ähm der andere.
Aber ist doch nicht automatisch in in diese Bibliothek aufgenommen worden als bekanntes.
Doch, doch, es ist ja genau an die gemeldet worden.
Nur weil's gemeldet wurde, ist es ja nicht automatisch auch in den nach außen zeigenden Verzeichnissen drin.
Doch das ist ja das also die okay könnte sein, dass sagt okay das jetzt nicht, ja? Viel Spaß mit denen zu verhandeln, ja? Also ich glaube da äh kannst du bei Google und Neck Mac hast du wahrscheinlich ähnlich gute Chancen, aber.
Punkt ist, sollte die Chatkontrolle nur mit Filtern auf bekanntes Material kommen.
Schön gut, ja? Dann kommt sie aber trotzdem mit dem Ansinnen,
der Behörden oder der Verpflichtung bei Finden von Material.
Eine zur Identifikation der Accountinhaberin geeignete Meldung an diese Europol-Stelle zu machen.
Konsequenz ist.
Erstens, wir haben dann durch die Hintertür und das war das, was Viktor auch immer schon betont hat, ähm ähm Viktor Schlüter, der ja auch äh mit uns zusammen mit Khalisi zu Gast war. Wir haben dann die die ähm Ausweispflicht,
fürs Internet, ja, weil im Zweifelsfall muss ja dein Signal oder dein Telegram oder wer auch immer.
Der Polizei sagen, wer du bist. Aber macht euch keine Sorgen. Das regeln wir einfach mit Videoident.
Nein, ist ein kleiner Scherz
kleiner Scherz am Strande. Nein, es ist natürlich ein es ist natürlich ein äh also das ist dann immer noch dabei und das heißt, der Kampf ist dann noch nicht äh
auch dann nicht gewonnen ja also ein ein wichtiges Problem ist vom Eis aber diese Identifizierungspflicht, also im Prinzip die
Personalausweispflicht fürs Internet ist da immer noch mit im Fahrwasser und deswegen ist diese Chatkontrolle hier wirklich ein äh Riesenproblem.
Ja kann das nicht oft genug betonen.
So, wir bleiben weiter bei Überwachung und Videoüberwachung.
Du kennst ja das äh Quartiersmanagement Grunewald, ne?
Ist mir ehrlich gesagt nicht bekannt.
Das kann nicht sein. Da kennst du auf jeden Fall Management Grunewald,
Also äh entstammt, sagen wir mal so, der Uhr einer Suppe der hedonistischen Internationale.
Und äh die haben wir so in Berlin ähm sind ja die die Maifeierlichkeiten,
häufig auf äh Friedrichshain, Kreuzberg, äh Prenzlauer Berg konzentriert. Äh teilweise seit den letzten Jahren ähm,
geht es dann auch oder in den letzten Jahren ging's dann auch mal durch Neukölln, ja und ähm.
Das heißt, äh diese diese Maifestivitäten finden in der Regel eben dort statt, wo,
auch die Leute mit der entsprechenden in der entsprechenden politischen Haltung oder ökonomischen Situationen sind. Und ähm,
was was man immer sehr oft gehört hat, war äh äh geht doch mal in Grunewald randalieren. Grunewald willenviertel,
im Westen von Berlin, ja.
Das hat man schon immer gehört, wollte man das gehört.
War so eine äh also das es war schon immer so ein Rat den der den äh Menschen gegeben wurde, weil es ja auch total ungünstig ist, wenn du dir deinen eigenen Bolle kaputt machst, weil dann kannst du am nächsten Tag nicht mehr einkaufen, ne?
Apropos Bolle, ja, großes Thema Bolle, äh Supermarkt, ich glaube Ende der Achtziger, Anfang der Neunziger, ähm nee, Anfang müssen wir noch mal genau gucken.
Glaube ich.
Also im Supermarkt abgefackelt in ähm Rahmen am am 1. Mai in Kreuzberg. Jahrelang,
Den äh linksradikalen Randalierern in die Schuhe geschoben bis dann irgendwann so ein äh Pyromane äh gefangen wurde,
im Rahmen seines Geständnisses dann auch erzählt hat, dass er beim ersten Mal in Kreuzberg völlig ohne ähm ohne politischen Hintergrund oder Beteiligung an den ersten Mai Diskussionen äh eben gedacht hat, ach ey,
günstigerer Moment kommt nie, ich zünde jetzt den Boller an und er hat den Supermarkt angezündet hat. Das war jahrelang irgendwie als das große linksextreme äh Gewaltverbrechen gegen Gegenstände äh,
Thema ist dann irgendwann rausgekommen ist, dass das halt eher so ein Turmane war, der die Gunst der Stunde genutzt hat.
Siebenundachtzig.
Siebenundachtzig sogar, okay. Ja, großes Thema? Äh äh wo wollen wir jetzt überhaupt?
Im Grunde.
Genau und dann dann ne, also wenn du jetzt in Kreuzberg wohnst, ist natürlich scheiße, wenn dein Supermarkt abgefackelt ist. So. Wenn einer in Grunewald abfackelt,
Na, ist ist jetzt für Grunewald scheiße, aber zumindest nicht für dich. Weshalb es dann den ähm den äh schon immer so ein Thema war, ob denn nicht man mal so eine Demonstration,
einfach mal nicht in Kreuzberg macht. Ja und das Quartiersmanagement Grunewald ähm hat sich dann dazu entschlossen,
Das ist also eine Vereinigung im Prinzip von Streetworderinnen, die den Problem Kiez Grunewald aufwerten möchten äh abwerten möchten, ja? Das ist ja eine äh Ghettoisierung, die da stattfindet, ja
ähm die Menschen ähm ja sind isoliert, die sind die integrieren sich nicht in das Berliner Leben und äh deswegen will das Quartiersmanagement eben da den Problemkiez abwerten,
ja
Parallelgesellschaft.
Genau, die Parallelgesellschaft auflösen. Das ganze Programm, ja ein bisschen sozialisiert, ne, ein bisschen Eingliederungsmaßnahmen, bisschen Resozialisierungsmaßnahmen anbieten und so weiter. So.
Und ähm da eben äh über gesellschaftliche Teilhabe, soziale Gerechtigkeit eben einfach Aufklärungs äh Arbeit leisten,
und ähm das machen die, glaube ich, seit 2018 da da hat das zum ersten Mal stattgefunden und,
Jetzt war natürlich die Polizei in in allerhöchster Aufruhr, dass diese Linken
nach Gronewald gehen, so, weil irgendwie so wenn die Kreuzberg in Schutt und Asche legen, also beziehungsweise sind ja gar nicht die Linken, sind ja in der Regel einfach irgendwelche 16-jährigen Krawall-Touristen, aber lange Rede, kurzer Sinn. Die könnten ja auch mit nach Grunewald kommen, das wäre schlecht. Entsprechend fand dann da so eine typische, bunte Demonstration der hindonistischen Internationale, ja
bei Sonnenschein, mit Musik und äh schöner Musik und so weiter, völlig friedlich äh in Grunewald statt, ja mit Spaziergang durch Grunewald und,
überall alles voll mit Bullen, ja und oben drüber ist noch ein Hubschrauber geflogen, ja, um um notfalls wahrscheinlich direkt das Feuer zu eröffnen, äh sobald der sobald der erste Mercedes äh einen Kratzer hat oder sowas, ja, ist aber.
Das Feuer zu löschen. Wenn der Bolle brennt.
Löschhubschrauber, ja? Wir alle kennen den Löschhubschrauber der Polizei, ne. Okay, also genau, so. Großes Thema und es gab im Rahmen dieser äh Quartiersmanagement Grunewaldgeschichten nie irgendwelche Probleme. Ja ähm.
Denn äh äh also bei beim ersten Mal wohl gab's irgendwie ein.
Irgendein Auf, da wurde ein Aufkleber an an Laternenpfahl gemacht oder so was, ne? Das war das war das waren da gab's natürlich schon Ermittlungen gegen wegen Landfriedensbruch, ja?
Krass. Die Leute können sich nicht benehmen.
Unglaublich, ne? Denken das, also das sieht da aus, dass wir wollen ja nicht, dass das in Grunewald aussieht wie in Friedrichshain-Kreuzberg, Prenzlauer Berg, Mitte Treptow und im Rest von Berlin, wo einfach mal man was an Laternenfall klebt.
Denk doch mal an die Bewohner, die sind das doch nicht gewohnt, wenn die dann irgendwie morgens äh rausgehen um mit ihrem SUV äh die Brötchen zu holen. Kino ein Schock.
Schock, ja. Wäre gut und dann haben Sie 20019 haben Sie dann äh das das Mike Rudi Stadtteil festgemacht, ja? Das muss man vielleicht auch erklären. Also in Berlin wurde dein Inneres auch schon boah äh,
oh jetzt 20 Jahre her. Das ist Mai.
Fest gestartet.
Haben sie nämlich dann da gesagt, okay Scheiße ist immer diese Mai Demonstration. Jetzt melden wir einfach früher was an und knallen die machen so ein Straßenfest mit Musik.
Äh dann dann können wir wenigstens aus dem 1. Mai in Kreuzberg äh irgendwie ein Profitcenter machen, ja? Und außerdem sind wir äh stehen wir den stehen wir da ein bisschen im Weg. Da muss die 1. Mai-Demo woanders lang gehen, oder,
ne ähm,
Das haben sie natürlich, das hat das Quartiersmanagement dann eben auch gemacht mit ja alles sehr sehr sehr also das ist wirklich sehr schön ja und dann äh gab es einen 219 die Mike Gruni Demo.
Da hat die Polizei alle Teilnehmerinnen anlasslos gefilmt. Ähm und zwar Kameras im Grunewalder Bahnhof,
wurden alle Anwesenden einfach unmittelbar registriert.
Und ähm das ist natürlich nicht erlaubt, weil insbesondere das anlasslose Film von Versammlung ist verboten. Und auch die An-und Abreisewege sind geschützt. Deswegen,
Vor allem vor dem Hintergrund, die haben ja auch alle schon besprochen hier, ne, äh automatisierte Gesichtserkennung, all diese Techniken, die es ja gibt. Ja und,
nicht vergessen, die zentrale äh biometrische Bilderdatenbank, auf die die alle Zugriff haben, ja, alles da.
Entsprechend äh haben nun äh die äh.
Wer ist denn wir sind ja jetzt die Klagen dann. Also insbesondere die äh also die das Quartiersmanagement Grunewald und dieses Forum Informatikerin für Frieden und gesellschaftliche Verantwortung haben,
geklagt.
Und das wird heute, wir haben ja heute den zweiundzwanzigsten 8 am Verwaltungsgericht Berlin verhandelt mündlich ähm und dann wird also äh vermutlich ein äh Urteil ergehen, sind wir sehr gespannt. Mhm.
Es ist auf jeden Fall,
Also ich kann's nicht anders sagen. Also beim erstens schaut euch wirklich mal die ganzen Aufzeichnungen an, ja. Das ist also das ist wirklich herzallerliebst diese ganze ähm,
des Quartiersmanagement gibt's schöne schöne Videos und so und dann auch ähm,
zum Beispiel Esels Alptraum, ein sehr schönes Duo, was ähm traditionelle Musik macht und so,
Alles sehr schön. Also der der der Klick lohnt sich und ähm genau Spendenstand äh ist gerade bei dreitausend Euro. Das ist nicht besonders hoch. Allerdings äh würde ich jetzt mal grade abwarten, wie's denn aussieht mit dem,
mit dem Urteil und so ja auf jeden Fall weißt du du musst dich ja irgendwie
gegen diese Dinge wehren
Ja? Das ist das ist ja wirklich schade, ne. Machst eine machst eine Demonstration und die ist wirklich, die sind immer lustig und schön, ne. Da ist jetzt nix da hat noch kein Bolle gebrannt in in Grunewald, ne, da hat überhaupt nichts gebrannt. Da hat vielleicht die eine oder andere äh zu zu lange Zigarette gebrannt oder so, ja? Aber da ist jetzt nix äh nix nix großartig schief gegangen so, ne.
Schöne Plakate auf jeden Fall. Der Trend geht zur Selbstenteignung.
Ich bin nur hier, weil ich eine Wohnung suche.
Lieb dich selbst wie dein Auto.
Es ist wirklich,
ähm da auch äh teilgenommen an diesen Demonstrationen. Das ist auch sehr also schon ganz lustig, wenn dann so diese Bewohnerinnen.
So mit skeptischem Blick hinter ihrem vier Meter hohen Tor,
von ihrem von ihrem Willengrundstück stehen und so durch das durch ihr Tor dann so skeptisch ähm das Quartiersmanagement bei der Begehung beäugen
ja ungefähr so wie das in Friedrichshall auch ist, wenn irgendwie die Investorinnen kommen und dann aber auch, wenn man dann so das Gespräch gesucht hat, ähm.
Also Verhalten äh freundlich waren, da hat dann wirklich auch gesellschaftliche Annäherungen stattgefunden. Ich würde sagen, da die Integration hat da durchaus auch beachtliche ähm Erfolge feiern können an an diesen Tagen.
Also liebe Bewohner des Grunewaldes raus aus der Parallelgesellschaft. Integration ist auch Frieden. Degration ist auch Liebe und es kommt euch nur zu Gute.
Und und ihr möchtet liebe Bewohnerinnen des Grunewaldes, ihr möchtet ja nicht, dass an eurem S-Bahnhof.
Grundrechte mit Füßen getreten werden. Das sind ja auch eure Grundrechte. Insofern würde ich euch empfehlen hier unter dem Verwendungszweck Videoklage 2020 an den Pfiff EV,
zu spenden.
Und einfach mal ein bisschen Selbstenteignung hier vorzunehmen im Sinne der der Integration.
So. Äh wer haben wir denn noch? Ach. Links unten ist keine kriminelle Vereinigung. Wir müssen's ja immer mal wieder damit angeben, wie lange wir ähm,
diesen Podcast schon machen. Links unten Punkt äh in die Media Punkt DE oder was? Ich weiß gar nicht mehr, was die Topflövel Domain war. Ähm die hatten.
Ähm das war 20 siebzehn, genau. 20 siebzehn August 20 siebzehn kurz vor der Bundestagswahl hat der damalige Bundesinnenminister Thomas de Maizire,
Links unten in die Media als äh kriminelle Vereidigung deklariert und verboten. So und äh.
Weil das eine nicht moderierte äh Online-Plattform war dann haben sie da irgendwie natürlich bei den.
Zugehörigen der kriminellen verbotenen Vereinigung irgendwie alles mögliche weggenommen.
Geld, Computer, Verfassungsschutz war dabei, ja und ähm.
Dann äh gab's eben die äh Verfahren und so weiter, Strafverfahren wurde eingestellt und so weiter. Jetzt haben wir zwanzig, zweiundzwanzig, ja? Es ist äh wenige Tage vor also fünf Jahre.
Hat es äh gedauert? Ziemlich genau fünf Jahre, elf Strafverfahren wurden schon 2019 eingestellt
Jetzt sind weitere Ermittlungen im Lande äh im im Sande äh verlaufen. Ja, nur weil einfach mal als Wahlkampfscherz Thomas de Maiziere mal irgendwie sagt, das ist jetzt eine kriminelle Vereinigung,
hatten diese Menschen jetzt fünf Jahre.
Schön wie du sagst, dass die Ermittlung im Sande verlaufen sind. Die Sendung, in der wir das berichtet haben, ist Logbuch-Netzpolitik 229 vom 14. September zwanzig siebzehn mit dem schönen Titel Daddel Sandburg ist auf Sand.
Okay. Also das ähm mm.
So dann hatte gab es am Ende waren sie vom Bundesverwaltungsgericht und da wurde die Klage danach mündlicher Verhandlung ab
gelehnt, also erst zugelassen, aber dann nach mündlicher Verhandlung abgelehnt
damit haben sie keine Entscheidung getroffen, ob das Vereinsverbot überhaupt rechtsmäßig war. Das wäre ja auch schlecht gewesen, weil dann hätten sie ja gesagt, dass der Innenminister Scheiße gebaut hat, also haben sie's lieber eingestellt. Ähm,
Und jetzt gibt es noch eine Verfassungsbeschwerde, die die Anwältin eingereicht haben. Äh gegen das äh,
Vereinsverbot und oh herrje ey das ist also ist wirklich irre ja? Geld haben sie den weggenommen. Das ist wirklich krass, ja. Äh wir hatten glaube ich auch damals darüber gesprochen auf dieser Webseite ist das ein oder andere Mal sind da äh fragwürdige Inhalte veröffentlicht worden
zum Beispiel personenbezogene Daten von bekannten Faschistinnen ähm und Ähnliches Material war dort häufig zu finden
ja, inhaltlich auf jeden Fall äh fragwürdig, aber äh ähm.
Nicht zu vergessen, ähm das kann erstmal auf jeder Seite passieren. Da hat jeder äh Plattform auch das Hosterprivileg, bis sie eben Kenntnis von solchen Inhalten hat und die dann,
löschen muss, ja? Da bist du aber noch keine kriminelle Vereinigung und wenn äh links unten eine,
kriminelle Vereinigung ist, dann was ist denn dann Facebook? Ja. Die ist einfach too big to big to äh,
ja? Da kann Thomas den Maizia nicht verbieten, da muss er irgendwie ein paar kleine Freiburger nehmen. Fünf Jahre Scheiße damit. Unglaublich, ich find's wirklich irre, ne?
Okay. Jetzt können wir neu machen, Tim.
Machen wir doch mal einen Leup. Es geht um Cookies. Unsere Lieblingsinteraktion im Internet. Täglich neu äh geübt.
Die sind meine Cookie Banner wegklicken. Ist geil. Ist geil. Ist geil.
Genau gibt's bei uns nicht mangels Cookies.
Nö. Wir haben nur so ein Battle-Banner, ne.
Wir haben nur so Battlebanner, ja. Das alles. Die sind aber äh da ist Nord noch nicht gegen vorgegangen.
Aber wehe, die kommen ja auch auf die falschen Ideen.
Gibt ja jetzt äh bei dieser Stelle, an dieser Stelle möchte ich euch gerne darauf hinweisen, es gibt jetzt Logbuch-Netzpolitik Plus. Ähm.
Da gibt's dich.
Okay, ja, genau. Äh Cookie Banner. Okay, also äh Noib geht hier, also nein auf ihr Business, die NGO von Max Shrems gegründet.
Geht gegen täuschende Cookie-Benner vor, ja? Also auch darüber haben wir hier öfter schon mal gesprochen, die gehen jetzt einfach in die nächste Runde. Ähm dieses typische, ne,
Ja, du musst jetzt eine informierte Entscheidung treffen, hier ist ein riesengroßer blinkender, blauer Knopf mit fünf Fallen dran, wo ja steht und unten gibt's ganz leicht grau, ja, ein ein,
ein Müll dunkler als das Weiß deines Bildschirms äh steht weitere Optionen
Dann kommen 580 Häkchen, die du wegmachen musst und ein klitzekleines Okay, was jedes Mal, wenn du mit der Maus draufgehst, äh woanders hinspringt, ja? So funktioniert der Cookie-Banner. Äh die darauf ausgelegt sind, dass du selbst wenn du,
ähm wirklich dir Mühe gibst ähm in der Regel, die nicht die nicht die Entscheidung klickst, die du ähm,
treffen möchtest,
Und äh ja da hat äh Neub jetzt äh weitere 226 Beschwerden äh äh,
eingereicht. Bei 18 Data Protection Offhorities bei äh Webseiten, die die äh Webs die diese Software OneTrust nutzen, die,
offenbar die Einstellung für täuschende Darstellung äh anbietet, ja.
Die wollen also jetzt äh weitermachen, immer mehr Leute mit Beschwerden überziehen und ähm,
ähm auch nicht nur sich mit äh auseinandersetzen, sondern auch mit Trust Arg,
und so weiter die diese entsprechenden äh Tracking äh Zustimmung machen. Jetzt denkt man sich eigentlich auch geil ja, ist es also offenbar inzwischen schon ein Geschäftsmodell?
Cookie-Banner zu machen, weil es so kompliziert ist, ja ist es, weil so viel ähm,
eingebunden wird von diesen werbefinanzierten Plattformen. Das ist quasi schon ein Geschäftsmodell ist, das Cookibaner zu bauen. Noch dazu natürlich in einer möglichst täuschenden
Variante, die die Nutzerin dazu bringt äh eine Entscheidung zu klicken, die sie nicht möchte und deswegen ist es eine Katastrophe und ich finde es sehr schön, dass Neub dagegen vorgeht. Insbesondere weil.
Diese Cookie-Banner ja von vielen Menschen, der äh sage ich mal allgemeinen Bevölkerung, also der Landbevölkerung, die nicht so online sind wie wie die meisten, ja, also Landratten. Ähm,
wahrgenommen wird als als Idiotie,
des Datenschutzes. Während es ja in Wirklichkeit eine ein Wahnsinn,
des Datenschutzgesetzes ist, ähm was da stattfindet und deswegen ist es äh richtig und gut und sinnvoll, dass Leute genau dadrauf kloppt. Ja, finde ich super.
Man merkt auf jeden Fall schon, wie diese Maßnahme,
Ergebnisse zeigt, das äh schreiben sie ja auch selbst in ihrer äh letzten Meldung, dass es schon durchaus eine hohe mittlerweile gäbe und tatsächlich auch so aus eigener Erfahrung wird dir wahrscheinlich eh nicht gegangen sein.
Ist äh zu beobachten, wie Webseiten in zunehmenden Maße
allem diese Banner vorschmeißen und dann ist prankte auf einmal ein genauso gefärbter der bis vor Kurzem da noch gar nicht war, sondern eben diese ganz
Hintertür äh Tricks, die du gerade korrekt beschrieben hast so, die jeder kennt, ne, wo dann die Leute irgendwann sagen, ah, ist mir doch egal, ich klicke jetzt hier auf das bunteste, Hauptsache ich kriege jetzt meinen Content.
Am krassesten finde ich, wenn du dann dann kriegst du da hundert1achtzig Optionen, klickst die alle weg und dann ist da unter aber nochmal der fette Button alle zulassen. Die haben geübt, ey, das ist ja richtig gut.
Ja aber Max.
Das ist immer eine generell, also was ja hier auch noch dahinter steckt, ist dieses Konzept des des der Dark Patterns.
Schon ein paar Mal angesprochen, ist so ein bisschen so der Fachbegriff äh wenn euch das interessiert, da unter dem ist eine Menge äh zu finden gibt's ja auch verschiedenste äh Gruppen und Divitals, die sich da
bemühen auch auf Twitter äh diese Praktiken immer mal wieder darzulegen. Das betrifft ja bei weitem nicht nur äh Cookie-Banner.
Das ist sozusagen das, was auf jeder Webseite zu finden ist, aber Dark Patterns
zum Beispiel auch generell dieses Versuch mal bei Facebook dein Account zu löschen, ja oder überhaupt versuch mal überhaupt irgendwo ein Abo zu beenden et cetera. Das sind ja alles Dinge, die in den letzten Monaten und Jahren
im Rahmen der EU-Regulierung tatsächlich ähm nach vorne gebracht wurden, ne. Also wenn zum Beispiel jetzt online,
ein Abo abgeschlossen wird, dann muss es auch an derselben Stelle wieder beendet werden können. Das war halt vorher nicht so.
Steht da so was wie rufen sie uns an, schreiben sie uns eine Mail, schreiben sie uns einen Brief, schreiben sie ein Fax, hängen sie irgendwas in ihren Garten, ja also
Alles wurde probiert, um die Leute möglichst lange in der Abhängigkeit zu behalten. Onboarding immer äh einfach, aber offboarding äh schwierig, ne? Also so eine
Internetreise und äh das.
Auch das äh ändert sich nur, dass eben diese Dark Patterns weit verbreitet sind und alles, was in irgendeiner Form einem schwierig gemacht werden kann,
Geldinteresse dahinter äh steckt, dass man irgendwas nicht tun soll, nicht können tun soll. Äh ja, das wird dann eben auch entsprechend schwer gestaltet und,
die dark bettern Liste ist da halt ewig lang.
Ja, so ist es. Es ist äh da könnte man eigentlich mal so eine also Excel-Meisterschaft erscheint mir vom Schwierigkeitsgrad noch ein bisschen einfach. So, Abo kündigen Meisterschaft.
Halbe Stunde.
Löschen Sie Ihren Facebook-Account, Sie haben zwei Stunden Zeit.
Sitzt hier so mit so mit so einer schönen mechanischen Tastatur und so Maus Tefler.
Irgendwie. Das weißt du.
Dass er eigentlich geil ja, Account.
Ein so
ja ja Accountlöschmeisterschaft oder Abo beenden Meisterschaft und dann halt auch so wie bei den Meisterschaften so mit Screensharing und dann siehst du die Leute da auf der Website schwitzen so ah klick hier nee Scheiße was was ist das denn, wo bin ich denn jetzt schon wieder? Oh jetzt bin ich wieder da. So vier null vier bekommen. Oh und so.
Oder und dann so oh so Kommentatorinnen dazu so oh jetzt jetzt muss die null,
Hotline angerufen werden. Warte, Melodie, das kann, das kostet,
Zeit und wertvolles Geld. Britta versucht es auf anderem Wege. Er schreibt einen Brief. Online Porto bestellt wird er oh die Anmeldung, dafür braucht er Videoident.
Das machen wir das ist doch echt schon super dat können wir echt machen beim. Da legen wir halt so ein paar Accounts an, weißt du?
Ist ja auch notwendig, damit die Leute, also die Leute dürfen ja nicht vorher wissen, was für einen Account sie sperren müssen. Das heißt, du machst einfach irgendwelche Accounts, dann lässt die Leute gegeneinander antreten.
Genau und dann machst du's genauso wie beim äh bei den Excel-Meisterschaften so acht Leute starten und dann kommen äh in der ersten Runde die ersten vier kommen dann in die nächste Runde
So und dann gibt's eine zweite, dritte äh Runde bis dann sozusagen der Sieger äh feststeht so und dann ja könnte lustig werden.
Und der und es und und und am Ende müssen sie einen Telekom-Anschluss bestellen. Das dauert aber dazu.
Falls jemand Bock hat, das umzusetzen, feel free.
Also das finde ich das äh wirklich das fände ich ein super Abendprogramm für einen Kongress.
Tim und ich können wir jetzt schon sagen, werden keine Zeit dafür haben. Aber äh.
Die Idee ist frei verfügbar.
Die Idee äh umgesetzt zu sehen würde uns sehr freuen. Vielleicht würde ich auch mal teilnehmen.
Ich bin übrigens im BSI Beirat digitaler Verbraucherschutz.
Ach. So so.
Man macht ja, ich habe ja nichts, ich habe ja nicht genug zu tun, ne. Ich lange bei.
Ist ja sozusagen ist ja schon fast seriös.
Ich langweile mich ja den ganzen Tag wie allen bekannt ist, ne. Ich bin ja so ein Snacker. Deswegen habe ich mir gedacht, dann dann mache ich halt eine ehrenamtliche Beiratsrolle beim BSI.
Zusammen mit äh Professor Doktor Martina Sasse von der Ruhruniversität Bochum. Dennis Romberg vom Verbraucherzentrale Bundesverband Philipp Ehmann vom
Eco-Verband der Internetwirtschaft Professor Hannes Federath äh der ist Vorsitzender der Gesellschaft für Informatik und in Hamburg Professor
Sven Herpick Stiftung neue Verantwortung,
Professor Martin Schmidt Kessel von der Uni Bayreuth Rebecca Weiß vom Bundesverband Informationswirtschaft,
und äh äh Bundesverband Informationswirtschaft, Telekommunikation und neue Medien und.
Helga, Zanderhayat, äh die von der Verbraucherzentrale NRW dabei ist und dann gibt's noch,
eine Person vom von der Stiftung Warentest, die hier auf der Webseite nicht gelistet ist und der Name mir deswegen jetzt grade spontan nicht einfällt, die Webseite Schuld nicht mein schlechtes Namengedächtnis. Wir haben jetzt eine erste Veröffentlichung ähm und zwar,
geht es da um die Sicherheit von Passwörtern beziehungsweise die äh ähm Anmeldung ja an Authentifizierungen.
Generell. Ähm ich denke, da ist jetzt nicht irgendwelcher,
irgendwas Neues drin, was äh was hier nicht alle wissen, aber ähm.
Trotzdem mal anschauen äh wo wir also sagen äh schwaches Passwort ist natürlich nicht gut, aber dann wird halt erstmal erklärt, was was ist eigentlich ein starkes Passwort, ja und dann das große Problem.
Ist ja erstens verwenden die Leute zu schwache Passwörter,
andererseits gleichzeitig für mehrere Accounts und beide Probleme müssen ja gelöst gelöst werden, indem,
Kontext empfehlen wir also sehr lange Passwörter, ja, Länge sticht Komplexität, also äh auch das habe ich glaube ich hier schon mehrfach erklärt, ja, wenn es eine Anforderung gibt, wenn ich eine Anforderung an ein Passwort habe, dann ist es die Länge,
weil die Länge steht ja im Exponenten, das heißt jeder,
Charakter mehr macht das Passwort sehr viel komplizierter während die Varianz der Zeichen in der Basis steht bei weitem also nicht so eine hohen Einfluss auf die Sicherheit des Passwortes hat.
Entsprechend äh setze ich eigentlich immer Passwörter, die so lang sind, wie es geht. Überall andere und speichere diese ähm in einem Passwortsafe und das.
Sollte sich vielleicht in dem Zusammenhang auch noch mal den Begriff Parshrase äh ein.
Absolut.
Prägen, weil dieses Passwort.
Ist schon der größte.
Irgendwie, dass sie sich dabei um ein Wort handelt, aber wenn man einfach sagt, ich gebe hier einen Satz ein, den ich mir auch äh leicht merken kann, sowas wie äh ich gehe immer um fünf Uhr äh.
Passwort verraten, Tim.
Schon mal hier.
Dreiundzwanzig Bonobo zweiundvierzig. Hat sie immer noch nicht geändert übrigens, ne?
Ja, das da hieß es ja auch Passwort und dann äh dachte ich mir so, ah okay.
Als der Tim sich gedacht, boah, ich mache noch zwei Zahlen dazu, auf die keiner.
Also denkt euch einfach irgendein ganz geläufigen Satz äh aus, den ihr euch jederzeit wieder wachrufen äh könnt, aber den ihr jetzt nicht permanent in eurer Außenkommunikation ähm benutzt.
Hat der Erdgeist übrigens glaube ich äh ich glaube, das war in dem Vortrag von Erdgeist und ähm Artur. Da hatte nämlich, da war jemand klug genug, ein lang
eine ausreichend lange Passfrage zu nutzen und der hatte offenbar ein Buch genommen, was bei ihm im Regal stand, wenn ich mich nicht täusche, weil das ein Buch von Linus Torwart ist. Ähm gute Idee, ja, also vielleicht nicht eins, was
also genau langer, langer Satz ein Lied, ein schönes Lied, ein äh oder einfach ein Satz, der für euch wichtig ist, ja. Mein Vater,
mir.
Satz in eurem Lieblingsbuch. So das ist einfach schon mal,
Also wenn es sich wirklich um etwas handelt, was man als solches erinnern muss und das sollte eigentlich nur der Passwortmanager selber sein,
Also dass man im Prinzip alle anderen seine superkryptischen Passwörter, die ohnehin automatisch generiert sind und die man sich so nie merken kann, äh.
Um das Schließfach zu öffnen, dafür sollte so ein Satz verwendet werden und dann seid ihr ganz äh gut dabei,
Perspektivisch denke ich, sehen wir jetzt auch grade den Trend hin zur Abschaffung von,
Passwörter, das ist ein Prozess, der wird wahrscheinlich noch lange dauern, aber das ist so das, was derzeit in die Betriebssysteme kommt und wo sich jetzt äh Google, Microsoft, Apple glaube ich, noch ein paar andere auch drauf geeinigt haben, dass sie das jetzt massiv,
unterstützen wollen, ist dieses Konzept eines Parks Keys und das ist dann eben sozusagen wirklich die
Nutzung digitaler Kryptographischer Verfahren so dass man eben gar nicht mehr selber ein Passwort eintippt sondern aus so einem sicheren Speicher wie man sie zum Beispiel im Smartphone hat also ne mit,
Identifizierung und dann wird halt einfach da ein Schlüssel ausgelesen,
Public Private Verfahren man lockt sich darüber ein ohne irgendwelche Passwörter noch einzugeben. Aber das ist etwas, wo wir jetzt gerade am Anfang stehen, aber so perspektivisch bewegt sich die Industrie halt weg von Passwörtern, weil sie
alle wissen, dass es an sich äh eine Technologie ist, die mehr äh Ärger macht, als man das haben will.
Das hätten wir niemals anfangen sollen mit den Passwörtern, äh mit den Passphasen, aber okay, wir wir werden besser, da steht auch natürlich der das ist der der andere Teil, der dann natürlich eine große Rolle noch drin spielt. Zwei Faktor Authentifizierung. Aber ich sehe schon Tim.
Passwörter, wir sind übrigens ein Fortschritt gegenüber dem Zustand davor, keine Passwörter.
Ja, aber weißt du.
Also das war in den Achtzigern der Stange.
Das ist ja eine illustre Runde, die das BSI sich da leistet, aber ich denke, dat hätten wir einfach auch kurz zu zweit machen können.
Kolleginnen und Kollegen im Beirat jetzt in keiner Form. Äh kritisiere ja eh kein Geld. Insofern hätte das jeder auch kein Geld sparen können. Insofern passt das schon. So dann ähm.
Letzte letzte Meldung, es gibt mal wieder Patientendaten im Netz, ja, die Zerforschung äh hat diesmal den äh Datensafe äh,
sich angeschaut, ja, eine.
Offenbar eine Anwendung, die Ärztinnen und Ärzten gegeben wird, wo dann irgendwelche Daten drauf sind und haben da Gesundheitsdaten von. Ich glaube, was waren das? Wie viele Millionen? Weiß jetzt gar nicht mehr, ob's fünf oder eine Million waren?
Menschen mehr als eine Million, ja? Mehr als eine Million Datensätze und äh.
Von einfach Menschen, die bei bei einem bei einer Hausärztin waren, die,
sich ein äh ein Produkt hat andrehen lassen von einer ähm mit dem Namen Datensafe, was jetzt erstmal ähm,
vielversprechend ist, ja und äh von der von einem Unternehmen mit dem wohlklingenden Namen Doc Zirkus, nee, Doc Zirus.
Circus, ja, da kann man ein weißte.
Der Arzt in der Wolke.
Aber wieder das Gleiche, ja, wo dann steht, dass wir alles Ende zu Ende verschlüsselt, ist es nicht. Du kannst überall alles raustragen,
komplette Ende zu Ende Verschlüsselung, ad absurdum geführt, äh dein Daten-Safe schickt die Daten
über die Cloud woanders hin, kriegst irgendwie die Krankenversicherung von den Leuten. Einmal alles, ne? Und das ganze Ding unterscheidet mal wieder nicht
ähm äh wo.
Wer wer worauf zugreifen kann und so ne also keine einzige äh sinnvolle.
Überlegungen da drin, ja? Also es ist einfach ich ich kann da auch, weißt du, das Problem ist.
Das müsse mal geschützt werden, dass dass man wenn man behauptet, dass so was.
Da müsste mal jemand äh das ist äh ich ich hätte das eingangs schon gesagt. Die Dinge, die ich.
In meiner beruflichen Tätigkeit mache, ne, die sind nicht so schwer. So wirklich nicht.
Werde nicht nicht müde zu betonen, so mein Ziel ist wirklich nicht also erstens, weil damit die Welt besser wird,
und zweitens weil es in in dieser Branche natürlich auch eine ganze Menge ähm ja Leute gibt, die besser in einer anderen Branche wären. Ähm,
Mein Ziel ist die Abschaffung der IT Security-Branche. Und zwar weil,
Eine bessere Welt wäre, wenn es die nicht mehr benötigen würde, ja? Aber dafür müsste Entwicklerinnen und Entwicklern eben gesagt werden.
Ihr macht das ordentlich und wir nutzen jetzt
weißt du, wir wir lernen, wie man sichere Architekturen baut und bauen auf deren Basis auf. Aber wenn die ganze Zeit immer irgendwelche Vöglein kommen,
denen das nie jemand beigebracht hat, solange du in einer Welt arbeitest, wo hier
Backentler und Frontendler, die arbeiten ja getrennt voneinander. Wie soll das denn funktionieren?
Ja? Wenn die wenn die also du hast ja andauernd die Fehler im Back-End, weil das Back-End dir zu viele Daten gibt. Ja? So,
Ja, die Frontentler entwickeln aber die ganze Zeit use cases, die Back-Endler haben irgendwie, ja, wir machen eine API. So, wunderbar. Wenn die aber nicht ordentlich zusammenarbeiten und die das Backend nicht die Use Cases und die App Use Cases kennt,
dann kommt eben so was bei raus. Ja und du brauchst für solche Dinge eben ein sinnvolles,
Datenmodell und ein sinnvolles Modell, wo du dem du dann einen Authentifizierungsmodell gegenüberstellst. Das Problem ist ja, bei der Authentifizierung, es gibt jetzt durchaus unterschiedliche Rollen, ja, dass du sagst, okay,
Du bist jetzt eine Nutzerin vom von der Privilegie Admin, du bist Nutzerin von der Privilegien Patient. Jetzt kommt eine Ärztin, die muss wieder was anderes sehen, ne.
Am Ende in solchen Projekten ist es dann regelmäßig so, dass die Frontentler sagen, na ja okay, ich kriege halt ein Bit von dem Back-End, ob ich jetzt welche Rolle ich habe, entsprechend mache ich die die Gui,
dann schicke ich halt auch noch nur noch die Requests, die ich machen will.
Dann kommt aber irgendjemand, schaut sich das mal an und sagt der, sagt der äh sagt der äh sagt dem Back-End, hör mal,
Mach doch mal bitte ein Rique, als wäre ich äh hier Super Adminat, ja klar, gar kein Thema. Und das passiert immer wieder am laufenden Band. Und du kannst es gar nicht mehr ertragen.
Du kannst es nicht mehr ertragen und irgendwie schreiben ja auch hier, ne.
Also zur Forschung schreiben. Die hier beschriebenen Fehlerquellen gehören zu den offensichtlichsten Fehlern.
Wie diese dürfen nicht passieren und zeigen krasse Defizite in den Entwicklungsprozessen im Unternehmen. Da helfen auch ganz viele Zertifizierungen nicht,
von denen das Unternehmen gleich eine ganze Reihe besitzt, ISO 9tausend, eins, ISO siebenundzwanzig, null, null, eins, ganz viele verschiedene von der von den äh KBV, also äh was ist das nochmal
Kassenärztliche Bundesvereinigung, ja und niemand,
bei diesen Zertifizierungen wird hier nicht das Produkt geprüft
Ja und dann kommt geht eine Person von zur Forschung zum Arzt, lässt lädt sich irgendwas runter und sagt, ah Scheiße, ey, jetzt habe ich wieder zwei Monate Spaß mit dem mit dem Pferd, mit dem vom BSI mit dem Datenschutz, mit diesem Unternehmen,
Da muss ich noch ins Fernsehen, nur weil die eine nicht bauen können, aber den Mut besitzen,
Den Mut besitzen, ein Produkt an den Markt zu bringen, was Datensafe heißt.
Das würde ich der garantierte Witz, ne? Geht ein Zerforscher zum Arzt.
Ja. In dem Fall war's glaube ich eine Zerforscherin. Äh aber.
Okay. Die Zerforscherin hat auf jeden Fall äh wieder auch schön unterhaltsam. Ihr müsst euch diesen Blogpost durchlesen. Das ist einfach grandios.
Sehr Forscherin geht zum Arzt, Arzt überlebt schwer. Im Arzt schwer verletzt oder so was, ne? Ey keine Ahnung. Es ist aber es ist wirklich zum Heul.
Es gibt auch einen Grund, ja, also wenn du schau dir Leute an, die Ahnung von Security haben, die machen entweder sehen die zu, dass sie gar nix bauen,
So so wie ich, also nee, nee, nee, alles schön hier äh wegkapseln, dass das äh stürzt alles eh ein, ja.
Oder Sie sehen zu, dass Sie irgendwie Systeme so klein wie möglich, so schmal wie möglich bauen, ja, irgendwie
so viel wie möglich Bload von anderen Projekten rausschneiden um den Coat managbar zu machen, ja? Das sind die, die Produkte bauen, ja, also zu sagen hier
alles so klein wie möglich. Man muss das alles noch verstehen. Alles so so eng wie möglich, da werden dann ernsthafte äh Sicherheitsprodukte äh gemacht,
und dann gibt es 95 Prozent des Marktes, die sagen ey sicher, da kommt keiner rein. Voll geil, ich habe hier fünf fünf Bachelorstudenten von der Fernuniversität Hagen, die bauen jetzt ein Datensafe.
Nichts gegen Bachelorstudenten vom von der Fernuniversität Hagen, aber äh solange das auch in keiner Universität,
einfach mal von vorneherein beigebracht wird, was wie man einen Zugriffsschutzbau braucht, sondern dann irgendwelche,
Sonderstudiengänge, IT Security, ne? Also gibt's ja zum Beispiel an ähm Bochum äh Professorin Sasse, ist da das beste Beispiel? Die hat einen sehr guten Ruf, ja, weil sie IT Security macht, aber getrennt von
IT im weitesten Sinne, ne. Da gibt es dann ein Institut, da gibt's einen Studiengang, das auch sehr gut.
Aber eigentlich müssen wir in einer Welt leben, äh in der IT-Sicherheit noch nicht einmal mehr ein getrenntes,
ein getrennte Spezialisierung ist, weil damit eben einhergeht, dass woanders Leute äh Yolo IT machen.
YOLO ist eh gut. So heißt ja hier äh falls äh falls dieses Jahr ein Kongress stattfindet,
die äh die Location im CC also ähm wenn man wenn wenn man mehrere Server zusammenstellt und sie dort hostet, ja, das nennt sich,
Kolo, Call Location, ja? Das ist also dein Rechenzentrum oder vielleicht ist er auch nicht fit, ne? Also wenn so ein Rack, wo du mehrere Server reinstellst, wo mehrere Leute sich rein, das nennt man Krolo.
Und in ähm in Hamburg gab's immer die Yolo-Kolo.
Da da waren die Server, wo man sagt, na ja okay.
Kann sein, dass die einer raustragen will, dann stellen wir mal nix in den Weg. So ähm sehr schön,
Okay, damit sind wir bei den Terminen.
Damit äh sind wir definitiv bei den Terminen.
Am 27. August öffnen über 50 Hacker Spaces ihre Türen und hoffen auf zahlreichen Besuch. Das ist glaube ich dieses Wochenende. Es ist diesen Samstag, ne?
Genau, das hatten wir auch schon mal, aber weil's jetzt soweit ist, dachte ich mir, können wir ja noch mal drauf hinweisen.
Könnt ihr auf die Karte klicken und dann.
Und in der Schweiz und Luxemburg, also Extended Germany. Dann äh wann ist das denn? Das ist auch diese Woche schon, ne?
Auch diese Woche und zwar gibt es,
eine Weizenbaumfilmnacht zu ehren äh von Herrn Weizen äh Baum. Professor äh früher Forscher der künstlichen Intelligenz und sie haben sich ausgesucht den,
tollen Film. Alles ist eins. Außer der 0 zu zeigen, das Ganze in Berlin ähm Freiluftkino in Kreuzberg findet äh statt an diesem,
Donnerstag, den fünfundzwanzigsten,
August und da könnt ihr euch also den Film nochmal anschauen in bei voraussichtlich ganz gutem Wetter und ähm,
Du warst da ursprünglich eingeladen. Ich bin dann eingesprungen. Das heißt, ich werde im Vorfeld
äh an einem kleinen tja einer kleinen Diskussionsrunde Panel et cetera äh noch teilnehmen. Das findest du eine Stunde vorher statt. Also wer so gegen 8 Uhr dort
aufschlägt, sollte das dann alles noch mitbekommen können,
Würde mich freuen, wenn ihr da auftaucht und äh wer den Film noch nicht gesehen hat, das ist dann halt auch eine Gelegenheit, das zu tun.
Ja, es ist echt äh und bei der Gelegenheit übrigens auch der Freilift Klinik Kreuzberg ist in Bethanien, ne? Das ist ein Mariannenplatz quasi.
Also weil wir heute so viel über Kreuzberg gesprochen haben, ne? Der Marianenplatz bla bla bla blau, so viele Bullen waren da. Mensch Meier musste heulen. Das war wohl der Film, der im Kino lief. Äh,
Kann man also sehr empfehlen Kreuzberg äh äh aus dieser Perspektive mit Hilfe von Tim noch einmal zu ergründen und,
Letzte Terminempfehlung. Witz und Bäume findet wieder statt und zwar vom 30. September bis 2. Oktober an der TU in Berlin. Äh TU ist ja eher hier, wie heißt das da,
Wie heißt denn dieser große Kreisverkehr, der so scheiße ist? Scheißverkehr. Nicht der mit der Goldese einen weiter noch. Also wenn du denkst.
Reuterplatz.
Reuterplatz, genau. Am Ernst-Reuter-Platz zwischen Großer-Stern und da äh auf dieser Strecke Tiergarten in der Nähe,
Findet die Konferenz für Digitalisierung und Nachhaltigkeit. Vom 30. September bis 2. Oktober statt. Tickets kann man jetzt kaufen gibt's zu unterschiedlichen.
Preisen, je nach äh dem, ob man sich als Unterstützerin oder Suffizienzteilnehmerin, Standardteilnehmer reden, Soliteilnehmerinnen und so weiter. Äh sieht ist für jede was dabei und äh
Das ist, wie wir alle wissen, die Konferenz für Digitalisierung und Nachhaltigkeit.
Das war's äh mit den Terminen und das war's dann auch.
Mit dieser Sendung, aber heute ist nicht alle Tage. Wir kommen wieder, keine Frage.
Nein, nein, da hinten nicht noch. Nicht noch Pink Panther. Das kann man so nicht machen.
Naja gibt's gibt's schlechtere äh Cultural Icons, die man jetzt hier hätte noch missbrauchen.
Der ist auch viel zu selten wiedergekommen. Nee, wir müssen jetzt wieder öfter Podcasten.
Sind wir euch nämlich schuldig, nachdem wir jetzt mal ein bisschen Auszeit genossen haben. Machen wir auch.
Also meine Auszeit war hauptsächlich weil ich zu viel zu tun hatte, aber ähm.
Ja, das tut mir natürlich sehr leid.
Ich Podcast ja auch im Urlaub mit dir, du ja nicht mit mir.
Jetzt lag's wieder an mir. Na toll.
So
Ja, aber noch was zu mitzuteilen? Eigentlich nicht, oder? Nee. Dann lassen wir das jetzt auch. Also Leute, bis dann.
Bis dahin, ciao ciao.